MEMBER WICKS NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. YOUR
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE OLDER OWN
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU JUNE
DAVID CHIU CHOI LISTEN TO
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
ALMOST REYES LOOSE RIVER ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEAM
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR WE ARE
ABOUT TO BEGIN. THE BUSINESS OF
THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS THE.
ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION WE
HAVE A QUORUM. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT MEMBERS. THERE IS WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER
I'LL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KOREA. LET US PRAY. LORD GOD
ALMIGHTY HOW YOUR CHILDREN HAVE
STRUGGLED IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. AND TO FOR
TO MANY YEARS TO COUNT.
SCRIPTURE HAS GOT SAYING AS I
HAVE LOVED YOU. SO MOST YOU
HAVE A SPECIAL PREFERENTIAL
CARE AND LOVE. FOR THE LITTLE
ORPHAN AND STRANGER. IN THE
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM LIBERATION
AND JUSTICE. LET US NOT FORGET
THE WIDOW THE ORPHAN AND THE
STRANGER WHOSE DIGNITY HAS BEEN
DENIED AND HIS BURDENS ARE MORE
THAN THEY CAN BEAR. I STRUGGLED
WITH THE WORDS OF THIS PRAYER
THAT'S WORLD IN MY SOUL WITH
THE MOTIONS THAT I HAVE COME TO
LEARN TO TEMPER. SURE ALSO
TEACHES US. I WILL SING ON TO
THE- AS LONG AS I LIVE. I WILL
SING PRAISE TO MY GOD. WHILE I
HAVE MIGHT BE. TODAY LORD I WAS
INSPIRED BY THE LYRICS TO THE
SONG. BY YOUR DAUGHTER NINA
SIMONE. I WISH I KNEW HER. IT
WOULD FEEL TO BE FREE. I WISH I
COULD RATE. ALL THE CHAINS
HOLDING ME. I WISH I COULD SAY
ALL THE THINGS I SHOULD SAY.
SAM LOUD AND SAM CLEAR. FOR THE
WHOLE ROUND WORLD TO HEAR. I
WISH I COULD SHARE ALL THE LOVE
IN MY HEART. AND REMOVE ALL THE
BARS THAT KEEP US APART. I WISH
YOU COULD KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE ME. THEN YOU'D SEE AND AGREE
THAT EVERY MAN SHOULD BE FREE.
I WISH I COULD LIVE LIKE I'M
LONGING TO LIVE. AND I WISH I
COULD DO ALL THE THINGS THAT I
CAN TO. AND THE ONE WAY OVERDUE
I'D BE STARTING A NEW. AND I
WISH I COULD BE LIKE A BIRD IN
THE SKY HOW SWEET IT WOULD BE.
IF I FOUND I COULD FLY I SORT
TO THE SUN AND LOOKED DOWN. AT
THE CITY THE NICE THING.
BECAUSE I KNOW. WHAT IT FEELS
TO BE FREE. LORD MAY TO GUIDE
US WITH THE WISDOM TO MAKE THE
IMPOSSIBLE POSSIBLE MAY WE BE
BLESSED BY YOUR GRACE TO LISTEN
TO GROW TO LEAD WITH CURRENT
COME. IN OUR WORK. AND IF WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN WALK WE CAN
DANCE AND IF WE CAN TALK WE CAN
SING. WITHIN YOUR PRAISES LORD.
AND IN THE FIGHT TO BE FREE. DO
WHAT IS RIGHT DO WHAT IS JUST.
AND DO WHAT IS NECESSARY. IN
HIS NAME AMEN. THANK YOU MISS
KOREA WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY FRAZIER AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CALLER PLEASE JOIN ME
IN. WE JUST ARE FIGHTING FOR. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. BEVERAGE
REMAIN STANDING PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING THEM. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAVE
UNDOUBTEDLY TOUCH THE LIVES OF
EACH AND EVERY CALIFORNIA. THIS
NOVEL VIRUS HAS LED TO THE
UNTIMELY LOSS OF MANY LIVES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. I ASK YOU
ALL TO OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE FOR THE COLD WITH
NINETEEN VICTIMS.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS. ONE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO MONDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
RECENTLY MET AT ONE PM THE ON
WILL COVER MULLIN SPEAKER FOR
TO WEAR THESE IN THE PRESIDING
CLERK SUPER TREATING FOR
KATHLEEN READING THE ROLES
CALLED AS THE MEMBER BROUGH
WOULD REQUIRE SO THE MOTION
TIME WHEN FIVE PM SUPER FOR THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS DOORS EVERY IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE EIGHTEEN
PM SPEAK FOR OR BONTA. AND MISS
FLORES THAT THE READING OF THE
DAY'S BE THIS. PRESENT
HABITATION THERE ARE NONE.
ENTER AND- OF. WE BE TO.
REPORTS OF WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND TO ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM
THE- THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THIS. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. YEAH ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
DOCTOR BILL QUIRK.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE WICKSON RAMOS TO SPEAK ON
A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
CORPORATION. SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY. ALL BILLS HAVE DEEMED
RECONSIDERATION. FILE ITEMS TWO
THROUGH FIVE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS
SIX. THROUGH FORTY EIGHT. PASS
AND RETAIN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY MISTER GRACE AND
MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
GRAYSON ACCOLADE AND HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. MR GRAYSON
FEMALE BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU A TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WILL ALLOW
IN HOME REPORTER MISSISSIPPI NO
READ. TO BE A PART. THEY
PROVIDED PLANTS MEET. THURMOND
THE IHS PRO IS A CAL PRO THAT
IS IN TO. LOW IN A BLIND AND
DISABLED PERSONS INCLUDE THE
RENT WHO ARE. RATHER HOME PLATE
FOR PROVIDER SERVICE
ASSESSMENTS RICK A TRAVELED FOR
CAO SOLD WORKERS WHICH THE
NUMBER OF CLIENTS THAT THEY CAN
BEAT THE THAT CAN BE REACHED IN
A SINGLE DAY FOR PLAYING REAL.
GET DEMAND HM US AND WITH THE
SITUATION REVOLVING AROUND CO
NINETEEN THE INTRO OF TELEPHONE
TO ASSESS WILL BE ABLE TO
STREAM ANNUAL REASSESSMENTS
ENSURE EVE GEN AT ACT. TO IS
WHAT LIKE THE MARBLE I.
QUESTION DEBATE ON THE ITEM-
QUIRK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICD NINE
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM FIFTY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY MEMBERS AB.
TWENTY FOUR. FORTY THREE
QUICKLY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FORTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER WEBER ANOTHER SAKHALIN
CONSUMER RIVER THESE DOCTOR
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE
ROCKS WAS AB. TWENTY FOUR FORTY
THREE. AND THE CAT CONSUMER LEE
REMEDY TO APPROVE THE RAY. OF
UNFAIR AND DECEPTIVE THIS IN
THE DEATHS AND- THE CARD
RECESSION IS MAKING IT CLEAR
THE MANY CALIFORNIANS WITH
INCREASINGLY WILL INCREASE THE
BASE FEAR OF FALLING BEHIND. ON
THEIR CREDIT CARD BILLS. WE CAN
HELP WITH THESE DAYS I HAVE TO
PAY THE- BEING THE- BY. WHO
TURN TO THE- AB TWENTY FOUR
FOUR WILL BRING. CLARIFICATION
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER LEGAL
REMEDIES. THEREFORE DELAY WELL
IN. RIGHT A SETTLEMENT CHAU
PEROT FURTHER THE BILL WAS
STRAIGHT CONSUMER FOR AROUND
THE MISSED. AND FRAUD COMMITTED
BY DE SETTLEMENT. IT TWENTY
FOUR FOUR THREE PER DOES NOT
DEFINE PROCESS EXCEPT THE
ADDRESS IS WRONG ACTS IN THE
BUT A DEBT RATHER THAN RISK.
FOR THIS IS TO. THIS CALL.
THAT'S TRUE THOUGH. WHO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR A FEE IS CHARGED
TO MARS TO APPROPRIATE THAT IS
IN. OF THE TERMS AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY THREE. THE IMITATION
CREATED NOW FEEL A PAY FROM.
THOSE AT AGAIN SIR AND DID
SETTLEMENT WITHOUT LIMITING
DIFFERENT TYPES OF YOU. OF THIS
PAGE PROCESS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. HOWEVER
SEEING NO GOT. ON THE ITEM.
CLICK OVER THERE ALL ALL
MEMBERS A- RETIRED ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE. A
LITTLE BIT. ALL OF DESIRABLE ON
THE. WELCOME ROLE TIE UP AS
FIFTY KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE OUT OF ONE IS AB
TWO EIGHT ALLOW BY MISTER.
MARGARET SO MIDDLE TO EIGHT
ELEVEN BY SOME MEMBERS BERMAN
OF RIGHT. THE BERMAN. IF YOU
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TWENTY
ELEVEN IT WOULD STE IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S AUTOMAT RENEWAL
LAW BY CRACKING ON THE OF
TACTICS THAT BUSINESS USE TO
MAKING INSIST. IN CAN BE CAN
TIME OR OTHERWISE. A TIME WHEN
MANY CALIFORNIA ARE NEEDING TO
COME BY. BY THE SERIES IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT ALSO
REQUIRE BUSINESS TO NOTRE
CONSUME BEFORE TRIAL PROMOTION.
WHICH IS PARTICULARLY IN GIVEN
TO NEXT. ENDING THE BILL IN THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS MANY OF THE
ISSUES RAISED BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS AB ELEVEN OUT OF
COMMITTEE UNIT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. THE
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
SUPPORTING A FREE MARKET DOES
NOT ALWAYS MEAN TOTALLY BEING
LAWS I FAIR BUT SOMETIMES
REQUIRES A LIGHT REGULAR. IN
ORDER TO PRESS MY- ONCE THE
FAILURE IS WHICH- IS A NOBLE
BARRIERS THAT ARE PUT UP WHEN
IT COMES TO SUBSCRIPTION
SERVICES TO THE CUSTOMERS DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SHOP
AROUND. FEDERAL THIS IS A
POSITIVE TO A- EARLIER ASPIRIN
I. THANK YOU KELLY. MR BERMAN
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH. CAN MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH HOWEVER I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ROSE OVER HIS
SUPPORT- AND RESPECTFULLY RIVAL.
THEY'RE ALL. THAT A VOTE
RESERVES ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLOSE ROLL
CALL VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN A PROUD OF FIFTY TWO.
THIS IS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP. FIVE FIFTY THREE.
THIS IS A. B. THIRTY TWO SIXTY
TWO. BY MR STONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK
STONE AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
THE CIVIL LIABILITY MR STONE.
AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO IS INTENDED TO CLOSE THE
GAP IN THE WAY THAT. PRODUCT'S
DEFECTIVE PRODUCTS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IF A
PRODUCT IS DEFECTIVE AND IT IS
SOLD. THE INTER PARTY CAN HAVE
REMEDY WITH THE RETAILER WITH
THEM YOUR FAX OR WITH ANYONE IN
IN THIS CHAIN AND THEY'RE VERY
CLEAR RULES ABOUT THAT. THE
PROBLEM I'M HOWEVER THAT WITH
ONLINE MARKETPLACE. HELLO SOME
OF THOSE COMPANIES THAT ARE
PROVIDING US ON THE MARKET
PLACES HAVE BEEN. EXEMPTING
THEMSELVES FROM THIS LIABILITY
AND IT'S LED TO A CASE WHERE
THERE WILL BE A PRODUCT OFFERED
ON AN ONLINE PLATFORM THAT
WOULD NEVER BE OFFERED ON.
BRICK AND MORTAR BECAUSE OF
LIVE. THANK YOU CAN GO ON TO
SOME OF THESE ONLINE. SITES AND
FIND ITEMS THAT ARE TRULY
DANGEROUS AND THAT HAVE HURT
PEOPLE BUT THEIR SOURCED FROM
PLACES OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IS NO REMEDY FOR THE
INJURED PARTY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES ALL IT REALLY DOES IS SAVE
YOUR MARKET PLACE. WHETHER
YOU'RE BRICK AND MORTAR MINE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE HELD TO THE
SAME PRODUCT BY THE DEATH
SHOULD ANYMORE PLACE ON. IS
THE- THING THE RETAIL. THAT'S
REALLY ALL IT IS AND THEN THERE
ARE A BUNCH OF EXEMPTIONS
BECAUSE WERE EXEMPTING THE
TROOPS HERE THE EBAY'S THAT
SEES. THAT THE- WEB SITES THAT
PROVIDE. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO BUY AND SELL AMONGST
THEMSELVES AND THAT WEBSITE
REALLY DOESN'T. PART IN THAT
TRANSACTION. BUT IF A WEBSITE
AT ALL FIND RETAILERS ACTING
LIKE A RETAILER THEY SHOULD BE
LIABLE. PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE
BROUGH IN CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE
WE NOW HAVE COME IN THE
CALIFORNIA THE PER WOULD HAVE
GOT OUR MARKETS BEFORE. AND
PEOPLE ARE BEING. THAT'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES BAD EQUITY IT'S A
FAIR IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PRODUCTS COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA OR YOU STAY FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS THEY POSSIBLY
EIGHT I ASK YOUR I'VE- THANK
YOU MISTER MISS WICKS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. BAKER THIS I THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FOR I'M PUTTING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD AND REALLY
THIS BILLS ABOUT SOME BASIC
FAIRNESS YOU KNOW THERE ARE
OTHERS THAT ARE BROKEN WATER.
BY THE FEDERAL. IF HE- IT'S
WITH OUR ONLINE RETAILERS THE
AS YOU ALL KNOW MANY YOUR
BUYING PRODUCTS ON AMAZON THIS
IS LIKE THIS ESPECIALLY THE
COVER NINETEEN WORLD I AM AS
WELL AND I HAVE A THREE YEAR.
AS YOU KNOW. I'M A LOT ABOUT.
IN AUGUST NINETEEN FOUND THAT
FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO I FOR SALE ON AMAZON DOT-
BY FEDERAL AGENCIES THEY WERE
ABLE TO SEPTEMBER THERE WAS
SUDDENLY LABELED WORK
COMPLETELY BANNED BY FEDERAL
FEDERAL REGULATORS IN THOSE
WERE ON SALE. ON AMAZON'S
PLATFORM AMAZON ITS DOORS THE
BILL. FOR THOSE PRODUCTS
CURRENTLY. THE STATE IS
PRODUCTS BUT AT LEAST A HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN I TELL THAT AMAZON
CONSIDERED BANNED INCLUDING A
MAP THAT THE FDA WARNS COULD
SUFFOCATE INFANTS. AMONG THOSE
I DIDN'T OR AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND LISTINGS FOR TOYS
CATION SELECT WARNINGS ABOUT
HEALTH RISKS TO CHILDREN. THE
JOURNAL COMMISSION TEST OF TEN
BUCKS TEN CHILDREN THANKS. I
BOUGHT ON AMAZON MANY PROMOTED
AS AMAZON CHOICE PROP- PROMOTED
HIGHER ABOUT PRODUCTS. 30%
BASED ON. ACCORDING TO THE
TESTING COME INCLUDING THE
BLOOD LEVEL THAT EXCEEDED
FEDERAL LIMITS THIS IS AGAIN
ABOUT BASIC FAIRNESS AND
ENSURING THAT ARE ONLY MARKET
EVEN. SAME CENTER. I WAS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MS WICKS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS HE COMMERCE IS THE WAY
THE FUTURE THERE'S NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT MY MIND AND IF YOU
DOUBT THAT YOU SHOULD COME TO
MY FRONT DOOR STEP. ANY BEEN
DAY THERE ARE PILES. SHOWING
UP. I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY
COME FROM. AND THEY MOSTLY SAY
AMAZON ON THEM SOMETIMES WAY
FOR. BUT WE'VE GOT UNDERSTAND A
CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE. FAIRNESS AND OPEN
COMPETITION IN THE MARKETPLACE
FOR THE FREE MARKET TO WORK. IF
YOU BUY A DOG. AT PACO FOR
EXAMPLE AND THAT DOG WHICH
BREAKS AND INJURES YOU YOU CAN
SUE PEKKA. TO GET REMEDY FOR
YOUR INJURY PACO CAN SUE THE
DOG LEASH DISTRIBUTOR AND THE
MANUFACTURE ON DOWN THE CHAIN
AND THERE'S INSURANCE- THE
PLIES YOU CAN. PULL HOWEVER
CONSIDER ACTS OF AN ACTUAL CASE
FROM THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA
SOMEBODY BOTTOM A DOG LEASH.
FROM A COMPANY CALLED THE FURRY
GET. WHICH IS LOCATED IN CHINA
THEY BOUGHT ON AMAZON. SHE WENT
WALKING FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH
THE DOG THE DOG LUNGED AT LEAST
NOT RICOCHETED BACK HERE IN THE
HIGH. WE BLOCKED HER ONE I.
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE. THE THIRD
SIR. FEDERAL COURT OF APPEALS
CONSIDER THIS ISSUE. AGAIN THE
VENUE LAW BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
LINE CALIFORNIA LAW
PENNSYLVANIA RIGHT NOW. THE
PERSON WHO WAS INJURED BY THE
DOG WHICH PERMANENTLY BLINDED
WENT TO SUE AMAZON AMAZON COULD
NOT FIND THE MANUFACTURED I
WISH THEY COULDN'T FIND HER
AGAIN. WHY BY NIGHT COMPANY
DISAPPEARED WASH JOURNAL HAS
REPORTED THAT 40% OF PRODUCTS
SOLD ON AMAZON ARE MANUFACTURED
IN CHINA. I WAS ON POLICY THE
ANYBODY THAT SELLS ON THEIR
PLATFORM HAS TO HAVE INSURANCE
AND HAVE HAS TO HAVE AN AGENT
FOR SERVICE OF PROCESS. JUST SO
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN. BUT IN
FACT THAT POLICY IS BADLY
ENFORCED OR NOT ENFORCED. THE
THIRD CIRCUIT FEDERAL COURT OF
APPEALS- THE PANEL MADE UP OF
APPOINTEES FROM PRESENTS A
DIFFERENT PARTIES I MIGHT ADD.
A RULE THAT PENNSYLVANIA LAW
HELLO AMAZON STRICTLY LIVE. IN
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES. I THINK
IT'S FAIR AND I THINK THAT
MODES HEALTHY COMPETITION.
ONLINE AGAIN IS THE WAY THE
FUTURE THE SAME WAY THE LAW
CURRENTLY TREATS. LOWE'S AND
HOME DEPOT. AND PEKKA I THINK
THAT'S RIGHT UP THIS IS A BIG
DEAL THIS BILL IS A BIG DEAL
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT'S A
BIG CHANGE SMALL. WOULD BE A
BIG TO DO THIS. THE LAWS MOVING
THIS WAY ANYWAY I THINK AS THIS
ISSUES CONSIDERED BY THE COURTS
OF APPEAL IN THE SUPREME COURT
THEY WILL LAND WHERE WE WENT
TODAY. HAS ASTUTELY. AMENDED
THE BILL TO TAKE OUT YOUR TRUE
AUCTION WEBSITES LIKE EBAY AND
ETSY. THOSE DO THIS BILL WOULD
NOT APPLY TO THEM. SO STAND
THAT IT'S TRULY TO ON LINE
ORDERS. I THINK IT WILL PROMOTE
COMPETITION. HEALTHY
COMPETITION. AND FAIRNESS IN
THE MARKETPLACE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EYE BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS IS TONY MAY CAUSE WE WISH.
WOW AFTER THE SPEECH I THINK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN LUIS
OBISPO- AFTER THAT SPEECH I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE I COULD
SAY OTHER THAN. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY THIS BILL WHICH IS WHY
MOST OF THE BILL FRANKLY IS
EXEMPTIONS WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE WE UNDERSTAND WHICH PLACE.
ENSURE THING LIKE THE RETAILERS
WHO ARE IN THAT BUT WE DO NOT
WANT TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO
BRING DANGEROUS PRODUCTS THE
CALIFORNIA I RESPECT ASK YOUR-
WITH THAT WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE TADARISE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. HAVE AND RETAIN ABOUT A
FIFTY FOUR. WE TAKE A PROUD OF
FIFTY FIVE A. B. THIRTY THREE
TWELVE BY MISTER GREGORY SO
MIDDLE THIRTY THREE TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT ACCOLADES
LOCAL GIRL. MR EMAIL AB THOUGHT
EXEMPTED ANNEXATION LAW TO
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF UC MERCED
THE TENT CAMPUS- NEWEST CAMPUS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- IN MY
DISTRICT CHECK FASTER. THANK
WAS GREAT SHE NOTICED CASH
REBATE. OUR CLUB IN A ROW. THE
SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASSED RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SIX. MEMBERS
WE ARE PROUD OF FIFTY SEVEN
THIS IS MR TANG'S TANGS A. B.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO. CLERK
WILL READ. SO MY BILL THIRTY AN
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING ACCOLADE ACCOUNT OF
ELEMENTS MR YOU MAY OPEN UP TO
MISS SPEAKER. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO LIVE IN A CONDOMINIUM OR
THE SUBDIVISION BUT WE HAD
EXPERIENCES HOME THE ASIANS.
PROBABLY DIDN'T KNOW IS MANY
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY
BEN THE ABILITY FOR THE OWNER
TO READ OUT THEIR PROPERTY. IS
SOLD THIS BILL. CLOSEST
LOOPHOLE FOR THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CANNOT YEAH. THE
RENTAL OF PRIVATE PROPERTY OF
AN OWNER- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE SO JUST
TO PROVIDE. DO THAT WILL THE
SENATE. YOU TO WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE THERE'S- HOW THE BILL
AFFECTS HOMEOWNERS SO FINANCING
IN SO AGAIN WITH EIGHT OF
HOUSING. BELOW THING ONE TO DO
IS STOP PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS
FOR BEING ABLE TO READ THEIR
HOMES THE OTHER. YEAH FIRST
WHAT FOR THE THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEM
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF NARAL. WELL IS OUT OF
ALL MEMBERS WERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU AYE AYES
FIFTY TO THAT MET PASSES. THIS
IS FOLLOWED FIFTY A A. B. TWO
THREE EIGHT BY DR WEBER. SOME
MIDDLE TWENTY THREE THE EIGHT
BY REMEMBER WEBER ACCOLADE TO.
DOCTOR WEBER. YEAH AB ONE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD THE
MISS AND CAL PENAL CIVIL AT
THREE TO PAY COURT. THIS WILL
PROVIDE VOEPEL A IN THE- TURN
IT IS SENT OPTION WHEN. NOW IN
AND TO BE FAIR LAW COURT OR-
UNDER A FAMILY THAT IS OUR ONLY
A LOT OF COMMITTEE HE SERVED AS
AN ARM. FOR MORE THAN FIVE NO
MORE THAN FIVE DAYS. ALTHOUGH
CONTENT MAYBE A USEFUL FORGET
COMPLY WITH THE CORE ORDER.
THEM FOR. THEIR SERVICE. I'M
GETTING A- OR PAYING
INDIVIDUALS BEING CHOI WITH
MODE COUNTS OF CAN FOR FAILURE
TO PAY. SUPPORT A UP TO. THIS
THE LIVES PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
THIS SIMPLY. SINCE AVAIL TO
SORT YOUR AND BASED CAN OFTEN
BE A BETTER ALTERNATE THAN IN
THIS BILL HAS A BY SUPPORT AS
WE SEE NO NO VOTE THAT I WAS.
ASK ME I'VE A BUT TWENTY THREE
EIGHT. THANK YOU DOCTOR MEMBERS
NOTICED KASHER DEBATE. WELL ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO DAMAGE
PASSED. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE
BY WICKS CORPORATION THE BILL
TO FOUR SIX THREE BY SOME
MEMORABLE WICKSON A CIVIL. MISS
WICKS. MR MEMBERS. AS YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN EXT MASSIVE AND FOUR
POINT MILLION PEOPLE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CREATING A LOT OF
FINANCIAL IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES. FOLKS
TURNED PERMANENT TREATED FOR.
AND MANY OF THESE HAVE DO GREAT
WORK AND THEY HELP US GET OUT
OF DEBT BUT SOME OF THEM ARE
ACTORS THIS BILL REALLY A- TO.
REGULATE THE BETTER. IS. SOME
MIGHT COME. TARGET LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS TO ENROLL AND THAT'S
CON FOR THE AFFORD AND HE'S
COME HAVE NOT BEEN FOR
REGULATED BECAUSE OF LIEU AND
LIE LICENSING LAW HE AND- MANY
OF THESE COMPANIES EVER. THEIR
SERVICE DURING SAVINGS TIMERS.
AND THEN. SAVE FORTY IN
ADDITION OF THE COMPANIES
CHARGED A REGISTRY THEY'RE NOT
HERE AND ANY SAVINGS OF. THIS
ARE THAN IN A WAY TWENTY
DECISION WITH DAMAGE CREDIT LOW
FROM CREDIT AND JUDGE AGAIN
THEM. THIS INDUSTRY NEEDS TO BE
RE. THE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR. WILL PROVIDE BACK IN
SLICE REQUIRE AND- TO STAB THE
NURSES GUARDRAIL. THAT WILL PUT
AFFORDABLE HEALTH. RECENT
MEMBERS EIGHT TO THE UP AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED TO FOR THE
OFFICE. IN ADDITION I'M
COMMITTED TO MAKING ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENT IN THE SENATE THAT
ADDRESSES THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNED THE FORTY CONTRA WHEN
THERE IS A CREDITOR. THIS EVENT
WAS MADE IN. THE DRESS IS
ANOTHER OF THE OFFICE IN
CONCERT. I'VE A LAW OF TIME
WITH THE OFFICE. TRYING TO AND
TO PLAY BUT THEY'RE MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH WELL HONORING
THE NEED TO PART ARKANSAS
HEARING CAL. ENTER THE BILL
FOLKS ON BROAD. REDUCTIONS
SPECIFICALLY WERE THAT SOME OF
THE COMPANIES TO AVOID NOT A
COULD. AND CAN SPEAK YOUR HONOR
ESTABLISHING REQUIREMENTS TO V.
O. TO THE- INDUSTRY MAKES BUT
WHICH IS NO RELAPSE LEADING
HEALTH. HOLDING BAD ACTING SOME
COMPANIES CANNIBAL AS THE D. B.
FORSMAN AMONG OTHER THINGS.
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR.
THE CAP FOR AND THEN TO ENSURE
REGULATION OVER BAD ACTORS. IF
WE DO NOT IF WE DO NOT A SET
REASONABLE. SORRY FOR NOT
RESERVE A ROOM FOR THE PRESENT
REASONABLE GUARDRAILS TO ABOUT
ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE WE WILL BE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FULL FORCE
FINANCIAL INSTABILITY. RESPECT
AS I. THANK YOU MISTER X.
SEEING NOTICE.
MEMBERS READING
COURT IS GOING TO READ AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR THAT
WAS THE SUBJECT OF MISS WEEKES
PRESENTATION CAR PLEASE READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AN
ACCOLADE FINANCE ONCE. MEMBERS
WE ARE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR YOU
HEARD MISS WITH TATIAN DO ANY
MA'AM SEEK. ON THE ITEM. MS
LIMON. THE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR IS A
BILL THAT WOULD CLOSE THE GAP
IN STATE OVERSIGHT IN THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES SPACE
DOESN'T COMPANIES MARKET THIS
IS TO CONSUMERS AND DEEPLY INTO
DEBT FEDERAL REGULATORS LIKE
THE FTC AND THE CFPB CONSUMER
HIVE. OF MARKETING AND IN
CERTAIN OUTCOMES THAT CAN
RESULT FROM ENGAGING WITH THESE.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES HAVE
OPERATED IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
MUCH OVERSIGHT AS THE ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM OAKLAND
MENTION THERE ARE LOOPHOLES IN
THE LAW THAT HAVE PREVENTED OUR
STATE REGULATOR DB O. FROM
ENFORCING THE PROVISIONS OF A
LICENSING LAW THAT HAS BEEN ON
THE BOOKS SINCE THE NINETEEN.
FIFTY WHILE DEBT SETTLEMENT TO
WORK FOR SAM WE ALSO HEAR FROM
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS WHO
WORK WITH CLIENTS WHO HAVE
TAKEN IT. INTAKE DOES SOME OF
THESE COME. CALIFORNIA'S THE-
TURN WITH THE HIGHEST LAW OF
HOUSEHOLDS. WE HAVE EVER SEEN
AND ACT MY CRISIS WILL PUT MANY
OF THESE CONSUMERS AN
IMPOSSIBLE. SINCE YOU'RE- DE. I
AM TO ENSURE THE- LETTERS I
WANT TO. AUTHORS REALLY TO WERE
WITH OP. AND I ASKED TO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS I REGION I
VOTE FOR AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MS THE MOUNT.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZING THEIR IN THE
CHAMBER YES- MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR. NOW MORE THAN EVER
YOU HEARD MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYED AND
FACING FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY.
TAKING ON DEBT TO SIMPLY
SURVIVE. SETTLEMENT COMPANIES
PROMISED TO HELP REDUCE THAT
DEBT BUT TOO OFTEN MANY BAD
ACTORS IN THIS INDUSTRY JUST
POCKET THERE FOR. IN THE US.
FAR. IT IS TO PURCHASE A HOME
BUY A CAR EVEN ELIGIBLE FOR LOW
INTEREST RATES. IF WE DON'T
ESTABLISH BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND REGULAR TAKE
REGULATIONS OF THE DEBT
SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY. AND HOLD
THESE BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE WE
WILL SEE MANY VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPER EVEN WORSE
FROM THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION.
IF I STRONGLY URGE MY FELLOW
MEMBERS TO VOTE I'D ON. TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU MS
WICKS. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
MISS WEEKES ITEM. LOCAL OF THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. KIRK WELL. CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL ME THE VOTE EYES FIFTY
TWO. THOSE TWELVE. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. AND MEMBERS BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER. THIS IS
GONNA BE A FILE ITEM FIFTY NOT.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS ACCOLADE
THE SELECTIONS MISS WHICH YOU
MAY GET OVER. ON THE RIGHT BILL
I MEAN I'M PLAYING THE
PREGNANCY ON PRIVACY BREAK ON
THAT HI GUYS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS. WITH AN
INCREASE IN EMPLOYMENT AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS EMERGING FROM
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY ALREADY BE
IN THAT LIKELY TO FIND
THEMSELVES IN EVEN GREATER
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. RESULTS
PRINT RECESSION HAVE SOME LONG
CAN CAN LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
AND HOMEOWNERS THEY ALSO BE
FACING THE THREAT OF LOSING
THEIR HOMES. THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER RECENTLY
COMPLETED A REPORT THAT
INVESTIGATED. A PROCESS FOR
CREDITORS HAVE BEEN SEEKING TO
FOR CLOSE UPON HOMES FOR SMALL
AMOUNTS OF AND SECURED THAT. IT
IS CLOSE I'M SPACE ON SMALL
AMOUNTS OF AND THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC IN EXACERBATES
EXISTING HOUSING. AND
HOMELESSNESS GRAY IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE DO INSURE
THOSE WHO ARE FACING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS CAN KEEP THEIR HOMES.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY THREE ONE
SURE THAT LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS
IN CALIFORNIA WILL NOT LOSE
THEIR HOMES AS THEY ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY DEBTS IT WILL
PREVENT FORECLOSURES ON A
PERSON'S PRINCE TO RESIDENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WICKS SEE NO
DISCUSSION. OUR CLUB- ALL. IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE SERVER. YEAH. YEAH. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED UP AYE AYES
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES ASCERTAIN ABOUT I'M
SIXTY THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE. THE TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO
CHAPARRAL MIDDLE TWENTY FOUR
FORTY TWO ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO
ACCOLADE FALSE INFORMATION MR
CHAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO WOULD
REQUIRE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
TO DISCLOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE A POLICY TO ADDRESS THE
SPREAD OF MISS AND FOR AN- I
FOR. TODAY'S THEY'RE ABOUT
VIOLATION UNDER THIS LAW
ACCORDING TO THE PEW RESEARCH
CENTER IN 201955% OF US ADULTS
GOT THEIR NEWS FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA IN YET ANOTHER REPORT
FOUND THAT DESPITE CONTROVERSY
AROUND FIGURE. 73% OF THEM
CONTINUE TO RELY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR NEWS. WHAT IS MORE
TROUBLING IS THAT APPROXIMATELY
50% OF THE PEOPLE SHARED A NEW
STORY. FIND OUT LATER THAT THE
NEWS WAS FALSE AS THE COVER
NINETEEN CRISIS CONTINUES TO
UNFOLD MANY INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN HIT WITH
MISINFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
VIRUS IS SPREAD WILL OFFERING
TO SELL MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO
FIGHT AGAINST THE IRIS. OR MORE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE AGE IN SOCIAL
MEDIA MORE INTIMATE. LEADING
AND IT TRUE CREATING ADMISSION.
I WOULD. TO ME FIVE FOUR TWO.
WHAT ARE THE SUCH A- USERS IN
THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ASSESS THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE CONSUMING.
ONLY ANY PLATFORMS DO NOT HAVE
A POLICY DEALING WITH
MISINFORMATION. SINCE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE IN FACT AN
INTEGRAL PART OF HOW PEOPLE
OBTAIN NEWS IT IS IMPORTANT TO
KNOW WHICH OF THESE PLATFORMS
ARE TAKING STEPS. TO ADDRESS
THIS OF MISSING FOR AN AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO DOT. WE
HAVE DRAFTED AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE MANY CONSISTS OF
THE OPPOSITION. BUT DUE TO THE
TIMING CONSTRAIN WE WILL HAVE
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE. AND I'M COMMITTED IN TO
DOING SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MICHELLE. SENIORDISCUSSION
DEBATE. OR CALL THE ROLL. WELL
IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I FORTY SIX DOES
TWELVE. THE MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO AND SIXTY THREE WORD FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR. THIS IS AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE AM IS
CARILLO PROPERLY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
INOCULATED CHILD SUPPORT IS
CORRECT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TAUGHT
ME TWENTY FIVE RESTORES THE
STATUE THAT EXPIRED LAST YEAR
AND ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
SUSPEND THEIR CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS WHILE INCARCERATED OR
INVOLUNTARILY ALL THAT AN
INSTITUTION FOR MORE THAN
NINETY DAYS. SINCE THE EXT OF
THE IT HAS BEEN MORE DIFFICULT
ALSO BE FOR LOCAL HELP SUPPORT
AGENCIES THE COURT. APPLY WITH
THE FEDERAL RULE IT HAS ALSO
WELL TO CONTINUE THE CREW OF
STUTTERING AMOUNTS TO CHAT A
DEBT MOST OF WHICH IS PAID WITH
THE TEMP PERCENT INTEREST RATE.
THE THOSE OF YOU WONDERING
HELLO. FORTY TWO. PEOPLE IN
PRINT IN ABOUT EIGHT AN HOUR.
WHICH THEY WANTED TO MEN OF
ACTION ALREADY THAT. THE TORT
FIVE. TWO XIN ANH AND FEES
LEAVING NO MONEY FOR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE RESTORED
THIS- THAT EXPIRED LAST YEAR.
AND IT IS VITAL TO AN
INCARCERATED PARENTS HAVE THE
SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY AND REUSE
CATION THAT THEY NEED WITH
THEIR WITH THEIR CHILDREN AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE NOT
HAVE ANY RIGHT THIRD OPPOSITION
A- REQUEST AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS GROUP. NOTICE. THEY'RE NOT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF.
AS FORTY FIVE KNOWS ONE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
FIVE. THREE SIXTY SEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AB THIRTY
SEVENTY BY DOCTOR WEBER.
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY BY SIMPLY MEMBER WEBER
AN ACCOLADE TO JURIES. AFTER
WEBER. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MEMBERS ARE
I AM HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
THIRTY SEVENTY WHICH WOULD
ADDRESS UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION
IN THE SELECTION OF JURIES
REGARDLESS OF INTENTIONAL OR
IMPLICIT BIAS BY USING AN
OBJECT YES TO DETERMINE WHETHER
DISCRIMINATION HAS OCCURRED AND
REQUIRING THE ATTORNEY
CHALLENGING A- THEY THREE. FOR
THE CHILD WHENEVER AN OBJECTION
IS MADE THAT THE CHALLENGE IS
DISCRIMINATORY. IS A MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS SINCE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN IN
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT RACIAL BIAS. IN THE USE OF
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES IT
CONSTITUTIONAL. YET PROSECUTORS
IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO
STRIKE. A BLACK AND LATINO
JURORS AT THIS. RATE PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BE CONVICTED JURIES
THAT NOT REFLECT THE DIVERSITY
OF STATE. THE PROSPECTS FOR A
FORCING THE AGAINST RACIAL BIAS
IN JURY SELECTION DOESN'T WORK
AND IT HASN'T IN AT AND NEEDS
TO BE FIXED. A RECENT THE I
BURKE OF. PLANET VALLEY THIRTY
IN OF THE CASES WHERE PRICE
TORCH. FOR OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR THE VIEW THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM IS RACIALLY AYE
ECONOMICALLY BIAS. AND 40% OF
CASES PROSECUTORS GAVE REASONS
BASED ON DEMEANOR OR APPEARANCE
INCLUDING THAT THE JUROR HAD
DREADLOCKS AND BRAIDS. IN 35%
OF CASES PROSECUTORS SAID IT.
BECAUSE A JUROR HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAD ONCE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND TWENTY OFFICE OF KATE. OR
THE- AT TECH WITH CRIMINAL
SYSTEM. JUSTICES IN CALIFORNIA
SAY PROP DOESN'T WORK IN
CHANGED. THE CIVIC WE JUST AS
GOOD WITH BLUE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT SAID IT IS PAST
TIME TO ASK WHETHER THE- THE
BATSON FRAMEWORK IS APPLIED BY
THIS COURT. SB RETHOUGHT IN
ORDER TO FULFILL THOSE
CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE OF
ELIMINATE RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
IN JURY SELECTIONS. TO YOU WELL
THE SUPREME WASHINGTON. PORT TO
PROVIDE. FOR THE FORCE. AGAINST
NATION SELECTION THE PROCESS
IMPLEMENTED IN WASHINGTON
RECOGNIZE IN PLACES BUYERS AND
USERS AN OBJECTIVE. STANDARD TO
ASSESS THE REMOVAL OF. WAS IN.
TO BY. EIGHT THIRTY SEVENTY IS
MODELED AFTER THE WASHINGTON
RULES FOR. THE PRE YES IS. TO
THE WORKING. SUPPORT FOUGHT
SLEEP. I RESPECT ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THIRTY. THANK YOU DOCTOR
MR BONTA YOU ARE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY EIGHT ISSUE A
PEREMPTORY STRIKES IS A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM IN THE JURY
SELECTION PROCESS RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
ARE EXCLUDED. FROM JURIES BUT
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES TIRADE
MUCH IS TWO POINT FIVE TIMES
HIGHER IN FACT THAN PROSPECTIVE
JURORS OF OTHER RACES
CURRENTLY. AND FOR THE
PROSECUTORS AE ALLOWED TO
JUSTIFY REMOVING PEOPLE OF
COLOR FOR JURIES FOR
PURPORTEDLY RATE. NEUTRAL
REASONS SB THIRTY SEVENTY WILL
PUT AN END TO THESE LEGAL
LOOPHOLES BY APPLYING AN
OBJECTIVE STANDARD AND
RECOGNIZING THE REMOVING A
JURY. BASED ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
ALSO NATION SB THIRTY SEVENTY
WILL HELP MAKE REAL THE PROMISE
OF A FAIR TRIAL BY AN IMPARTIAL
JURY THEN THIS IS AN ONE STEP
IN CREATING A- AND MORE JUST
SOME CHANGED WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
ON THE FLOOR AND THAT WE NEED.
AND DESERVE I RESPECTFULLY URGE
IVEL COLLEAGUES. AMOS BONTA MR
TANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR FOR A. B.
THIRTY SEVENTY AS WE ALL KNOW
THE KEY TO OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
IS A RIGHT TO A JURY OF OUR
PEERS. WE CAN'T HAVE A JURY OF
OUR RISK OF CERTAIN MEMBERS OF
OUR SOCIETY CONSTANTLY GET
REMOVED FROM JURIES WE'VE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO AND CALLING FROM WHEN.
YOU'RE HOW THE T. N. MERRICK IN.
I'M ARE KEPT. WITHOUT
PARTICIPATION CAN HAVE A FAIR
JURY THIS IS AGAIN A BILL
THAT'S MODELED AFTER THE STATE
OF WASHINGTON IS CONSIDERED A
MODEL PROGRAM FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT OUR-
SYSTEM. CAN HE AN OBJECTIVE IN
NEW TO AND HAVE AN AT SOLUTION
FOR ALL OF US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER TANK. THIS. DO ANY
OTHER MEMBERS SEEK RECOGNITION.
SEEING A DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IDLE FOR AB THIRTY SEVENTY OR
CALL THE ROLL. AND MEMBERS OF.
THAT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. PARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
KNOWS ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE AND SEVENTY BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE A.
B. NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY
MISTER LOWE CORKERY SOME AGO
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER LOW AN ACCOLADE
APPEALING ARE. MISTER LOW. MUCH
MISS THERE'S A EIGHT NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT. HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT WE SHIFT WITH RESPECT TO
TELL DENTISTRY- THE LIABILITY
FROM THE CONSUMER TO THE
COMPANIES. AS WE'VE ALL HEARD
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CURRENTLY
HAS INVESTIGATIONS ON A NUMBER
OF FRAUDULENT PRACTICES WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY AND THIS IS A
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER LOWE. SAYING NOTE
YES DOCTOR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THE SET TOPIC I
ACTUALLY KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT-
AFTER. ALMOST THIRTY YEARS OF
PRACTICE- THERE ARE THERE ARE A-
THERE ARE PROCEDURES AND THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THE
MARKET PLACE IT REALLY CONCERN
ME. TELL IT MYSTERY CAN ONLY GO
SO FAR- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE ORTHODONTICS.
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY JUST A
COSMETIC PROCEDURE. IT IS THE
IT IS THE APPLIED FORCE. THAT
BREAKS DOWN BONE. AND THEN
CREATES A SITUATION WHERE USE
CREATE ADDITIONAL BONE TO
SUPPORT THE TEETH THAT IS A
MEDICAL PROCEDURE. AND IT NEEDS
TO VISION. AND IT NEEDS GOOD
DIAGNOSTIC RECORDS TO START
WITH. ANY NEEDS HONESTY. AND
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING THE MARKETPLACE THAT
VIOLATE THAT. IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS NOT JUST A
COSMETIC PROCEDURE. I HAD
SHOULDER SURGERY. IN DECEMBER
MY DOCTOR I WASN'T REALLY SURE
THAT I HAD A TEAR IN MY ROTATOR
CUFF. HE SAID WE CAN ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW THE X. RAYS ARE
INCONCLUSIVE WE COULD WE CAN
GET CONTINUE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
BUT IT'S NOT WORKING FOR YOU. I
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE THAT
DIAGNOSTIC STAFF. AND SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON. AND THE MRI
SHOWED THAT I HAD A COMPLETE
TEAR MY ROTATOR CUFF. WE KNEW
THAT. THERE ARE SITUATIONS THAT
ARE HAPPENING IN THE MARKET
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE ARE ARE
GETTING A LINERS WITHOUT BASIC
DIAGNOSTIC X. RAYS WHY IS THAT
A BIG DEAL WOULD YOU BUILD YOUR
HOUSE ON A FOUNDATION WITHOUT
MAKING SURE THE FOUNDATION WAS
OKAY. WOULD YOU WANT YOUR TEETH
MOVED AROUND IF YOU HAD DENTAL
DECAY AND DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
WHAT IF YOU HAD AN ABSCESS
SOMEWHERE. AND STARTED MOVING
TEETH AROUND WHAT IF YOU HAD AN
IMPACTED WISDOM TOOTH AND
STARTED MOVING TEETH AROUND.
ALL THOSE ARE REALLY BAD THINGS
QUITE FRANKLY WHAT IF YOU HAD
THE BEGINNINGS OF GUM DISEASE
AND DIDN'T KNOW IT BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE A PHYSICS EXAM BY A
DENTIST WHO CAN MEASURE THE
POCKETS AND TAKE THOSE DENTAL
X. RAYS TO MAKE SURE. THAT YOU
HAD A HEALTHY THE COULD
ACTUALLY WITHSTAND THESE
PROCEDURES. WHAT'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE. IS ESSENTIALLY MAIL
ORDER ORTHODONTICS WITHOUT THE
SUPERVISION WITHOUT THE
PHYSICAL SUPERVISION OF ANY.
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL AND THAT
IS WRONG. THE BOARD OF DENTAL
EXAMINERS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ARE THERE TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY. THAT'S
WHAT THIS WAS ALL ABOUT. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I URGE
YOU. TO RELY ON SCIENCE. I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR BRING
THIS FOR. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION MISTER LOW
YOU MAY CLOSE YOU WISH I HAVE
NOTHING BAD BETTER THIS TO SAY
THEN THE LINE IN THE COMMENTS
WITH THE GOOD DOCTOR FROM HILLS
BURKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THE CLUB. SEVERAL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. KIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE. TALBOT EYES
FIFTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES PASSED RETAIN A
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO. FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THREE. AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY OPERATE SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
INOCULATE TO EMPLOYMENT. IT'S
GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER LAST YEAR WE
PASSED SB FIVE AND I KNOW. THE
DRESS CLASSIFICATION AB BUT HIS
TECH FOR DECADES WAS NOT
FINISHED I MADE IT CLEAR THAT
IN UNDER TWO MAGNITUDE BE A
MULTI YEAR EFFORT TO GET IT
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX TO START DO YOU. AND
MY COLLEAGUES TO CONTINUE TO
APPROACH ME TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY COLLABORATIVELY
THROUGH THESE COMP ISSUES. IN
AB TEEN T. I'VE MAKE
CLARIFICATIONS PROVIDE GREATER
CERTAINTY FOR MUSICIANS WRITERS
AND CERTIFY TRANSLATORS FOR
PHOTOGRAPHERS MULTIMEDIA
PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONALS
PROVIDING RISK MANAGEMENT AND
APPRAISAL SERVICES. EXPERT
JUDGES SPECIALIZED ARTISTS TO
TEACH IN OTHERS THE LAW. THE
PROCESS OF CRAFTING REASON. XIN
FOR EACH INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
CONSISTENTLY INFORMED BY THE
PRINCIPLES FOUND IN THE
DYNAMICS KATE ITSELF. IF I
CONTINUE TO WORK IN EMPLOYMENT
FEEDBACK FROM WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES I INTEND TO ADDRESS
THE FOLLOWING THINGS IN THE
SENATE. ISSUE ASSEMBLY RACE BY
INTERPRETERS WHO WORK THROUGH
REFERRAL AGENCIES BROADENING
THE MISSION OF A REFERRAL. TO
MAKE SURE. TO MAKE. IT IS NOT
COMPLETE PATIENTS. TOGGLE TO
WANT TO FOR PROP LATER THEIR
CONTACT. FOR ARTIST TO PRESENT
THE ORIGINAL WORK IN DRESS ANY
OUTSIDE ISSUES A WILL HELP FROM
COMPLY BY HIGHER BIZ. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I SO
WE CAN TO GRAPPLE WITH THIS
COMPLEX ISSUE. THANK YOU MS
GONZALEZ MISTER KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WHEN THIS BILL WAS IN
COMMITTEE- YOU SAID QUOTE THEY
WERE RIGHT I WAS WRONG. YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT WRITERS BUT YOU
COULD JUST AS WELL I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE TWENTY OR SO.
FASHIONS THAT THIS BILL FREEZE
FROM THE CLUTCHES OF AB FIVE TO
VARYING DEGREES. NOW I COMMEND
THE ADMISSION OF RESPONSIBILITY
AND I MEAN THAT SINCERELY. BUT
IT ISN'T JUST THAT YOU ARE
WRONG. IT'S THAT YOU
LEGISLATIVE THAT MISTAKE. YOU
GIVEN THE FORCE OF LAW PLEASE
POINT OF ORDER MISTER CALDERON
HE SAID HE HAD A QUESTION HE
NEEDS ASKS QUESTIONS WHERE
WHERE IS WELL TAKEN MISTER
KILEY PLEASE FRAME YOUR
QUESTIONS TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MADE DRESSES. THAT'S WHAT I'M
DOING. YOU GIVEN THE FORCE OF
LAW BEFORE MAKING SURE THAT YOU
ARE RIGHT. AND THE RESULT WAS.
INCALCULABLE HARDSHIP. AND
HEARTBREAK FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE
IN OUR STATE. SO JUST LOKING
AT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE AFFECTED
EITHER AND- PROFESSIONS
AFFECTED. BY THIS BILL. WE'VE
SEEN BUSINESSES SHUTTERED. SEEN
OUR LIVES UPENDED WE'VE SEEN
CAREERS RUINED. SO MY QUESTION
ASSEMBLY WOMAN YES IF BY YOUR
OWN ADMISSION. OR WRONG ABOUT
SO MANY PROFESSIONS AT SUCH A
HIGH HUMAN COST LAST YEAR. WHY
SHOULD WE BE CONFIDENT TODAY
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE
HUNDREDS OF PROFESSIONS THAT
REMAINED SUBJECT EIGHTY FIVE.
I'M GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION DESPITE THE FACT THAT.
I DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING IN. THE
REASON I SAID THAT IT HAD TO DO
SPECIFICALLY WITH HOW WE DEALT
WITH FREELANCE WRITERS. DURING
THE PROCESS OF AB I'VE I MET
WITH ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENTED FREELANCE WRITERS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS WE WENT DOWN
A PATH ON MISSIONS A LOT OF YOU
AT THIS THE THIRTY SIX
EMISSIONS. CATIONS CENTERED
AROUND THE NUMBERS. WHAT'S WITH
ORGAN IS THAT SELL. WHO
REPRESENTED FREELANCE WRITERS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS. AFTER IT WAS
SIGNED. AND PEOPLE REALIZE THIS
CAME IN A DIFFERENT GROUP OF
WRITERS WHO WHO WROTE IN A
DIFFERENT FASHION CAME TO SEE
ME AND THEY SAID THE SUBMISSION
ISSUE WON'T WORK FOR US I HAD
NEVER HEARD. FROM THEM THROUGH
THE PROP. IN THAT WORK BECAUSE
A BLOG THAT MIGHT BE ONE
SUBMISSION RATHER THAN YOU'RE
THINKING OF A STORY IN WHICH- I
TOOK COUNTLESS MEETINGS. THEM
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND. THE
MISSION THAT YOU WERE RIGHT I
WAS WRONG HAD TO DO WITH. IT IT
CAN'T WORK FOR THEM. AND SO WE
HAVE ADJUSTED IT AND CONTINUE
TO DO AS WE HEAR FROM. THE
JEWELS WHO HAVE ISSUES. THE
FACT IS OUR LABOR CODE WASN'T
MEANT AND WHAT DAY. HUNDREDS OF
EXAMPLES IN SD I A WHY WHERE
THEIR EXEMPTIONS IN THOSE
EXEMPTIONS AND CLARIFICATIONS
HAVE BEEN DONE OVER YEARS AND
OUR CODE. THE SUPREME COURT
GAVE US A BLUNT OBJECT AN ABC
TEST BUT APPLIED TO EVERYBODY.
AND THE KEY WITH HOURS THAT
I'VE ACTUALLY SPENT NOT ONLINE
TWEEDY MY DISSATISFACTION. BUT
ACTUALLY SPENT WITH INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS AND BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRIES AND ATTORNEYS. IT'S
TO GET IT RIGHT AND WHEN WE
DON'T GET A PERFECTLY RIGHT TO
ADJUST IT. BECAUSE AFTER FORTY
YEARS OF MASSIVE MISS
CLASSIFICATION. IN A SUPREME
COURT DECISION THAT PROVIDED A
LOT OF GUIDANCE BUT REALLY NO
SPECIFIC PATH. THIS IS
IMPORTANT WORK TO DO. SO I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO DO IT DESPITE
THIS COMPLETE INABILITY DESPITE
MY OFFERS TO SIT DOWN WITH ANY
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE WHO
WANTS TO COME TALK TO ME ABOUT
THIS. AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE YOUR CRITICISM AND YOUR
QUESTIONS BUT IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF YOU ACTUALLY THOUGHT TO FIX
THIS. FIX WHAT NEXT GAVE US TO.
WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WORKERS ARE PROTECTED
BECAUSE DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE
HAVE LEARNED MORE THAN EVER WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WORKERS
HAVE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
WE'VE LEARNED WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WORKERS HAVE
PAID SICK DAYS WHERE THEY HAVE
ONLY LEAVE. HEALTH CARE. RATHER
THAN JUST TRYING TO BLOW IT UP.
AND SUGGEST THAT SOMEHOW THE
BARTENDER AT A CATERING
BUSINESS SHOULD BE IN IT
CONTRACTOR THEY WERE NEVER.
WELL THAT'S JUST FLAMBOYANT
POLITICAL TALK IN NOT SEEKING
SOLUTIONS I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
SEEK SOLUTIONS NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO WORK THROUGH THIS.
MR KILEY YOU MAY CONCLUDE YOUR
REMARKS. TO BE CLEAR I DID
ATTEMPT TO FIX IT WITH THE
BILL- MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR ATTEMPTED TO FIX IT WITH A
BILL OF HIS OWN. NEITHER
RECEIVED A HEARING. THIS IS
BEEN THE STANDARD RESPONSE
WE'VE GOTTEN TO ALL OF THE
BREAKING. NEW OKAY PERFECT
WE'RE WORKING. IT OUT WE'RE
MEETING WITH PEOPLE. THAT'S
WHAT YOU DO BEFORE YOU PASS THE-
NOT. A YES WE HER SIGN. THE
RELEASE. BETWEEN AND GOVERNMENT
THIRTY SECONDS. NO NOW I CAN I
HER TIME IS NOT COUNT TOWARDS
MY SPEECH. IT USED TO BE WHERE
YOU HAVE THE SECONDS REMAINING
I DO NOT HAVE THIRTY SECONDS
REMAINING HIS RECOUNTING HER
TIME. IS THAT POINT OF ORDER.
WE SHOULD HAVE A WHEN YOU ASK A
QUESTION IS ADDRESSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE CLOCK IS
RUNNING IT WAS A LONG QUESTION
A CONSIDERABLE ANSWER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE YOUR YOUR POINTS WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL DEBATE. ON THE
FLOOR. THAT IS NEVER A THAT
RULES BEEN ENFORCED IN THIS
CHAMBER THE EXPRESSION IS ON MY
OWN TIME BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
COUNTING THE RESPONSE. BUT I
WILL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
THAT I KNOW THERE'S ANOTHER
BILL ON THIS TOPIC SO I ILL
USE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY MISTER
OBERNOLTE. YOUR RECOGNIZE I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF
THIS BILL MAKES SOME MODEST
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE FRAMEWORK
OF AB FIVE LAST YEAR- IN THE
SPIRIT OF TRYING TO BE HELPFUL
I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST SOME WAYS.
THAT IT COULD BE FURTHER
IMPROVED UNFORTUNATELY THE
CORONAVIRUS SITUATION IN THE
SHORTENED LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR
CURTAILED. OUR ABILITY TO HAVE
THAT DEBATE THIS YEAR BUT MAKE
NO MISTAKE IS A DEBATE. NEEDS
TO BE HAD. SO THIS BILL ADDS A
COUPLE MORE PROFESSIONS TO THE
LIST OF INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
GOOD EXAMPLES. FOR OUR
GOVERNMENT BY THE CARRILLO TEST.
FORTUNE IT ALL STRAIGHT ONE
PROBLEM THE BEEF. AB FIVE SAYS
HERE THE NEW RULES FOR WORKER
CLASSIFICATION IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEN SPENDS PAGES AND PAGES
AND PAGES OF STATE CODE TALKING
ABOUT EXEMPTIONS EXEMPTIONS FOR
THIS INDUSTRY EXEMPTIONS FOR
THAT N. STREET. BILL ATTIC
EXEMPTIONS FOR MUSICIANS RADIC
EXEMPTIONS FOR YOU SPORTS
COACHES WERE EXEMPTIONS FOR
INSURANCE AGENTS BUT LET ME
SUGGEST THAT THE WAY THAT THE
BILL SHOULD WORK IN THE WAY
THAT STATE COACH WOULD WORK.
THAT WOULD BE FINE- PLAN WORK
THAT WAY. EVERYBODY AND I A
COUPLE SUBJECT IN THAT LINE I.
THE WE EXPAND THE PROFESSIONS
UNDER AB FIVE TO CALL ALL OF
THE PROFESSIONS IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE THOSE ARE
PROFESSIONS THAT ALREADY HAVE
CODE SECTIONS DEDICATED TO THEM
WE CAN LEGISLATE- TWEAKS TO.
THE RULES FOR THOSE INDUSTRIES
UNDER THE BNP CODE I DON'T
THINK THAT WE NEED TO GO
INDUSTRY- UP A BY INDUSTRY IN-
THE FRAMEWORK OF AB FIVE. I
ALSO THINK WHAT'S BADLY NEEDED
HIS BIGGEST TURN FOR HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKERS. THAT IS
SOMETHING WE WOULDN'T BE
INVENTING THE WHEEL THAT'S ARE
FAR AND STATE CODE IN THE WAGE.
ARE THOSE. THAT HAVE THE POWER
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THEIR
EMPLOYERS AND I THINK THAT AN
EXEMPTION FOR THEM WOULD REALLY
HELP TO CLICK. BY THE BIG. SO
AB FIVE IS IT SAYS THAT. IF
YOUR WORKERS PERFORMING WORK
THAT'S IN THE USUAL COURSE OF A
BUSINESS FOR A COMPANY THAT
COMPANY CANNOT CLASSIFY THEM.
AS EMPTY AS A- CONTRACTOR BUT
WE NEVER DEFINE. WHAT USUAL
COURSE OF BUSINESS MEANS AND
UNFORTUNATELY AT LACK OF
SPECIFICITY JUST THROWS IT OPEN
TO THE COURT. THE
INTERPRETATION OF THAT CODE
SECTION AND FRANKLY THAT IS THE
PROBLEM THAT LED TO THE
ORIGINAL WORLD DECISION. AND
THE DYNAMICS DECISION IS THIS
LEGISLATURE'S. TO DEFINE IT
STATE CODE EXACTLY REMAIN. TO
FIX THE PROBLEM. AND THEN
LASTLY LET ME SAY THAT WE BADLY
NEED TO CREATE A SMALL BUSINESS
EXEMPTION IN AB FIVE. YOU KNOW
THE THIRTY YEARS AGO I STARTED
A COMPANY OUT OF MY COLLEGE
DORM ROOM I CAN TELL YOU WITH
1100% CERTAINTY I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN IT. AB FIVE THEN THE
LAW AND- COLLEAGUES IS TOO HARD
TO START A BUSINESS. WITH
TRYING TO HIRE EMPLOYEES AND
COMPLY WITH A COMPLEX FRAMEWORK
AND DELETIONS THAT THAT
ENTAILS. SO I FEAR. THAT AB
FIVE. WORK FOR THE COMPANIES
THAT IS REALLY GOING TO HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON
ENTREPRENEUR REALLY. CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY. COMPANIES THAT
THAT AT THAT ARE CREATED HERE
AND THE JOBS THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ADDED HERE WILL STILL BE
CREATED. BUT THEY'LL BE CREATED
AND OTHER STATES IN THE
PROSPERITY THAT COMES WITH THEM
WILL BE TOO. SO I. THE WAY I
HAD ONE THAT THIS YEAR. HEARD
WHAT ARE THIS LEGISLATURE. YEAH.
CERTAINLY MAKES SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE FRAMEWORK
OUR OF MODEST AND I WOULD URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE MISTER KALRA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AND I WHAT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
OUR COLLEAGUES IN AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS BILL-
DOES MAKE IMPROVEMENTS THE
REALITY IS- DYNAMAX WAS A
LANDMARK CASE OF THAT THEN
THROUGH UPON US LEGISLATURE TO
TRY NOT JUST TO INTERPRET BUT
WITH THE SAID IT WAS VERY CLEAR
AND CLASSIFICATION. AND MADE
ISSUE MANY. AB GIVE US OUR- TO
TRY OUR TO. THE INTER. OF THAT
CASE IN HOW IT'S ACTUALLY
DEFINE AND A- ULTIMATELY BY THE
STATE- BY THE ADMINISTRATION. I
AND I JUST WANT ABOVE I FELT
THE NEED TO AT LEAST RESPOND.
TO THE RANGE OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM ROOSEVELT- THAT A BILL
WASN'T HEARD. MY COMMITTEE JUST
LIKE MANY OTHERS THE BILL THAT
WAS HEARD WAS THIRD 240% OF
THOSE WERE INTRODUCED WE DID
HAVE A LOT OF BILLS THAT WERE
INTRODUCED RELATED- TO DYNAMICS
AND RELATED TO AB FIVE BOTH
REPUBLICAN AND- DEMOCRAT. A
BIPARTISAN BILLS THAT WERE PUT
FORWARD OF THE FARMER JORDY OF
THOSE ENTITIES BILLS NEVER
ACTUALLY SPOKE TO ME ABOUT
BILLS THEY INTRODUCE WE DID
HAVE A BIPARTISAN BOWED BUT
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT BILL
IDEAS THAT WERE BROUGHT TO ME
THAT WERE ACTUALLY
INCORPORATED. SUBSEQUENTLY.
MISTER CALDERON STAGE ONE ORDER
I JUST WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS
THAT WERE HERE TALKING ABOUT AB
FIFTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THE
SUBJECT MATTER WITH WHICH YOU
SPEAK HAS TO BE ON OF THAT BILL
DIRECTLY WITH THE SUBJECT
MATTER THAT IS IN. THAT BILL
NOT ON ANYTHING ELSE I JUST
WANT MEMBERS TO PLEASE STAY ON
POINT WITH THE SUBJECT MATTR
THAT IS ACTUALLY IN THIS BILL
THAT WE ARE TO BE. RIGHT NOW.
AT POINT OF ORDER IS. MISTER
AROUND YOUR CAR CAN FIND TIME
AS TO WHAT IS YOUR MAIN O THE-
AND FOR OF THE BODY. THANK YOU
AND I WAS MINOR. POINT IS THAT.
THOSE I'D HAVE BEEN A COURT. IN
THIS A LOT. BECAUSE THOSE
AUTHORS ACTUALLY REACHED OUT.
TO THE LABOR COMMITTEE THEY
ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO THE
AUTHOR- OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THOSE ARE NEVER ONCE CALLED ME
TALK TO ME. ACTUALLY PASS HIM
UP. TIME THIS BILL IS NOT
OUTRAGED GET A- AND SO THE TWO
RAGE BE REAL. BUT THE RAY OF
THAT IS BEING A- HERE DOES NOT
REPRESENT HOW BILLS GET PASSED
IN THIS ABOUT. OR GET THIS.
IT'S NO WONDER DOESN'T HAVE
MANY TO HIS NAME. IS BECAUSE
YOU ACTUALLY TO TALK TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES I ACTUALLY HAVE TO
WORK YES YOU HAVE TO. WITH YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN ORDER TO TRY TO
FIND COMMON GROUND AND THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS AMERICANS OFF
US HAS DONE EVEN WHEN SHE CAN'T
FIND COMMON. WITH CALL. HER
DOORS BEEN OPEN FOR THE I
COMMANDER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA MISTER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE RICH. THANK
MISTER SPEAKER PERMISSION TO
READ. MR MANHATTAN JUST A
HEADLINE FROM LAW PLEASE
CONFIRM WITH THE THAT STOP THE
CLOCK PLEASE COME THE COULD
MAJOR LEADER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
MISTER MATHIS MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU FOR PERMISSION MISTER
SPEAKER. SHOW MEMBERS WHEN I
WANT TO READ HERE IS FROM THE-
GLOBAL NEWS WIRE. THE HEAD
LAMBERT HEADLINE READS THE
FUTURE OF WORK IS HERE.
FREELANCE ECONOMY OFFERS
UNPARALLELED OPPORTUNITY FOR
GROWTH MOVES TO CLOSE THE
GENDER GAP. THE FIRST PARAGRAPH
OF THIS ARTICLE READS. NEW YORK
FEBRUARY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY.
PIONEERED TODAY ISSUED ITS
FREELANCE ECONOMY REPORT BASED
ON A SURVEY OF OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND FREELANCERS FROM OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY COUNTRIES
PROVIDING NEW INSIGHT INTO THE
WORLD OF FREELANCERS. THEIR
MOTIVATIONS AND HOW THEIR
UNIQUE WORK FORCE AND POWERS OF
GLOBAL COLLABORATORS BY
CONNECTING TOP. TALENT WITH
BUSINESS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THE REPORT TELLS THE STORY OF
AN AMBITIOUS AND COURAGEOUS
WORK FORCE THAT IS ON WILLING
TO SETTLE FOR THE STATUS QUO.
FREELANCING POPULARITY IS
ATTRIBUTED TO THE POTENTIAL FOR
GREATER JOB OPPORTUNITY.
INDEPENDENCE HIGHER INCOMES AND
A PROMISING MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF WAGE EQUALITY.
MEMBERS WE HEAR THESE THINGS OF
CLOSING THE WAGE GAP WOULD YOU
QUALITY. BETTER OPPORTUNITY
DALY. MY QUESTION TO YOU AS WE
VOTE ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ANY ANYTHING
DEALING WITH THE FREELANCER
ECONOMY IS TO REALLY THINK ON
WHAT WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS
BECAUSE THE EXPERTS IN THE
ECONOMY TELL US THAT THE
FREELANCE ECONOMY. IS CLOSING
THAT GAP IS PROVIDING BETTER
OPPORTUNITY THIS PROVIDING
BETTER ECONOMICAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR EVERYONE. IN TO PREACH A
QUALITY IN EQUITY. WE NEED
REALLY CONSIDER THESE THINGS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE I WANT
TO CLOSE BY INVITING ANY MEMBER
OF THIS LEGISLATURE IF YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY IN MANY OF YOU
HAVE TO COME TALK TO ME ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AS IT MOVES FORWARD
SAME AS LAST YEAR. THE WORD
LIVER THE DYNAMICS TO. AND A
LOT OF YOU HAVE HONESTLY COME
UP TO ME AND SAY. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE SUNBECAUSE WHO TO
BE. TO THIS. I DO MIND THAT BE
WHEN HAPPENED BOTH BUSINESS
FAMILY. CAME RUNNING TWICE FOR
CLARA. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH IT'S THE
BIGGEST LABOR LAW CHANGES IN
DECADES IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO DO THAT. BUT
A SPEECH FOR THREE MINUTES ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TO GET YOUR
POINT ACROSS SUGGESTS TO ME
WHEN YOU'VE NEVER STEPPED INTO
MY OFFICE THAT YOU'RE NOT
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT FIXING
WHATEVER IF YOU HAVE. IT'S JUST
ME THAT YOU'RE MORE CONCERNED
WITH MAKING A POLITICAL
STATEMENT. THIS IS NOT A
POLITICAL STATEMENT TO ME. I
KNOW THAT FREELANCERS IF YOU
WILL INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
THEY HAVE NO PROTECTIONS FOR
PAY EQUITY. THEY HAVE NO
PROTECTIONS FOR RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. THEY HAVE NO
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE AS
EMPLOYEES. AND SO TO READ FROM
AN ARTICLE IN SUGGEST THAT'S AN
ECONOMIC EXPERT ON THE FLOOR
WHEN YOU'VE NEVER COME TALK TO
ME ABOUT ANY ISSUE CONCERNING
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE. AGAIN
SUGGESTS TO ME THAT YOU'RE NOT
SEEKING SALUTE SEEKING. THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM HERE FOR
ME THROUGH THE- PIECE OF THIS.
WITH MUSE. OWN THANK ALL THE
INDUSTRY FOLKS WORKERS.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COME TO ME
ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT WE
COULD WORK THROUGH THEM AND GET
IT RIGHT. I AM COMMITTED TO
GETTING. THIS ALL MEANS. MY
WORK. BUT IF WE'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT TRYING TO FIX AS MUCH AS
WE CAN FOR AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE
CAN'T INSTALL IT HERE TOO EIGHT
FIVE ARTISTS AND UNANIMOUS
SUPREME COURT THAT LAID OUT
SPECIFICALLY THE PROBLEMS THEY
SAW AS THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN
LIVE OVER AND OVER AND OVER A-
AND IT'S NOT. HAVE BEEN. BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC THE LITTLE TOUGH
NOW TO ASK EIGHTY DID ANYTHING
BUT WE ARE MATH CLASS OF NUMBER.
AND IN SOME OF YOU KNOW YOUR
WORKED IN THE FIELDS YOU'VE
SEEN. THE MATH CLASS OF. AND
CAN. THE CLASS WITH THAT WE
HAPPENING BY THE WAY AND HEALTH.
THE BEFORE DYNAMAX THOUSAND
WORKERS WERE FOUND
MISCLASSIFIED BY ET DE NOT
BECAUSE SOMEBODY COMPLAIN
BECAUSE JUST THROUGH AN AUDIT
PROCEDURE. FOUR THOUSAND
MUSICIANS FOUR THOUSAND
INTERPRETERS. THIS IS A REAL
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE'S
LIVES IN A CAME TO BEAR WITH ME
FAMILY LOST THEIR JOB IN HAD NO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. IN NO
SAFETY NET IN NOBILITY TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR FAMILY SOME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I HOPE
YOU'LL VOTE FOR THIS I HOPE
MOST OF YOU BELIEVE AS LIKE
FROM BIG BEAR SAID IT'S MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I'D
GET AN INVITE YOU TO COME TALK
TO ME ABOUT ANY OF THESE ISSUES.
THOSE WHO HAVE I'LL- WE WERE.
ALWAYS AGREE A HUNDRED FOR. BUT
WILL. THROUGH WHERE WE'RE GOING
AND WHY. IT'S NOT RANDOM. IF
YOU LOOK AT OUR CURRENT YOU Y.
CODE IT LOOKS A LITTLE RANDOM
BUT WE YOU KNOW THAT THAT CAME
ABOUT FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY TO
TWO THOUSAND ALL THE EXEMPTIONS
THERE WERE TRYING TO. FIT FORTY
YEARS. OF LABOR LAWS INTO. IT'S
A LOT OF WHAT. I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN THIS WORK AND I ASK
YOU TO VOTE I IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU MS HAS ALSO ACTOR FOR
OF THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MY VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE WROTE BUT I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR A. B.
NINETEEN THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME AGO NINETEEN THIRTY
BY SIMPLY MEDINA AND OTHERS
ACCOLADE THE FEELS EDUCATION TO
CLEAR VIEW TO SEE THERE ARE
SICK FOR MEDIALLY MISTER MEDINA
YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT IT TO BE NOT.
THIRTY YESTERDAY. YOUR THE
CHAMBER WAS A HISTORIC DAY. AS
WE PASS. A FIVE. TO GIVE VOTERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OVERTURN
PROPOSITION TWO OH NINE. BUT A
NAME THAT WAS NOT MENTIONED IN
YESTERDAY'S DEBATE. WAS A
GENTLEMAN BY THE NAME OF WARD
CONNERLY. WARD CONNERLY WAS A
UC REGENT. SB FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PASSED
PROPOSITION. TWO OH NINE. THE
UC BECAME THE FIRST. HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTION IN THE
COUNTRY TO GET RID OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. SO YOU SEE YOU GOT
RID OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE LED BY
WARD CONNERLY THE FOLLOWING
YEAR HE ALSO HELPED SPEAR. BOB
THE PASSING OF PROPOSITION. TWO
OH NINE. WHEN YOU SEE. GOT RID
OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER I SAW THE
NUMBERS OF LATINO AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS INYO IN UC. A
LOT OF. CERTAINLY LORD WE SAW
ALSO IN THE SCHOOLS THE
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS THE
SCHOOLS OF MEDICINE RULES OF
LAW UCLA UC BERKELEY SAW THOSE
NUMBERS ALSO GO DOWN. THIS PAST
YEAR WE SAW CSU. ASKS OR NOT
ASKS BUT OF REYES ARE THERE
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS. ATTY A
AN EXTRA YEAR OF. OF A
QUANTITATIVE REASONING AS PART
OF THEIR ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS
THEY DID IT WITH OUT ANY
CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITH K.
TWELVE OR WITH THE LEAD LATER
FOR THAT MATTER. AND THEN AFTER
MUCH DEBATE AFTER HUNDREDS OF
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS CAME OUT IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REQUIREMENT FOR
CSU. AND AFTER HEARING HERE BY
HIGHER ED. COMMITTEE SEE ISSUE
AGREED TO POSTPONE OR TO NOT
IMPLEMENT THE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING OF REQUIREMENT. AS
CHAIR OF HIGHER ED I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT IT IS. WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING. AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO REMOVE OBSTACLES.
SO THAT WE CAN INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MINORITY STUDENTS
LIKE THE YOU KNOW AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN BOTH CSU AND UC.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S
REQUIRED CSU TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT TO GIVE MORE
OVERSIGHT FOR THEM TO. MAKE
SURE THAT THEY STUDY THE IMPACT
OF WHAT. CHANGING THEIR
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS WOULD DO
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
MINORITY STUDENTS. AND WOULD
INCLUDE COORDINATED
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS WITH
PUBLIC ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS. SO AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THIRTY IS AN IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT NECESSARY TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE AND FAIR ADMISSIONS.
NINETEEN THIRTY AS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF.
ALL MEMBERS THE TO THEIR IT.
ALL MEMBERS THE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY VOTE I SIXTY ONE
NEWS. ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
ONE NEWS HERE THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE. WILL PAY AND RETAIN
FILE SEVEN FIVE IN. SEVENTY
MEANWHILE IN SEVENTY FIVE. THIS
THROUGH WE'VE COME TO THE OF
THE FOR PRESENTE. AT AB TWO ONE
TWENTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME A BILL TO ONE TO TWO BY
SIMPLY BY BLOCKER RUBIO IN
ACCOLADE CANNABIS AND A PRO.
FOR YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SO AND THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO
THE ON A SOME BILL TWO ONE
TWENTY. AN ACT RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT OF A NICE KIND OF
THE BUSINESS IS AS YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF BE ISSUING A SINCE AT
THE BEGINNING OF TWO EIGHTEEN.
CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO IN THE
STATE TODAY DESPITE FOR THE
SINGLE BIGGEST ISSUE THE AND-
OF A LEGAL. EIGHT IS THAT WE
HAVE A THREE LEGAL GET THREE OR
FOUR. IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING
TAX REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
THREATS TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL WILL TARGET THE
ILLICIT MARKET BY CREATING
CIVIL PENALTIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
FOUND TO BE AIDING AND ABETTING
THE SALE OF A LICENSE CANNABIS.
EXAMPLES OF EIGHTY SEVEN COULD
BE AN ADVERTISER WHO KNOWINGLY
AND INTENTIONALLY DIRECTS
BUSINESSES TO AN UNLICENSED
SHOP AS WE HAVE SEEN IN PAST
YEARS. ANOTHER EXAMPLE COULD BE
A PROPERTY OWNER KNOWINGLY
ACCEPT TO LEASE HIS OUR
PROPERTY FOR THE EAGLES TO
OPERATE IN THE CITY BACK TO
SLIP. BILL A FROM LOW
GOVERNMENT LAW FORCED BUSINESS
AND LABOR ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BY PARK
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED BY ARISES SUPPORT IS
ACTUALLY REALLY IMPORTANT BILL
BECAUSE THESE ILLEGAL OPERATORS
UNDER CUTTING. THE ONES THAT
ARE TRYING TO DO IT RIGHT THE
ONES TRYING TO DO AND LEGAL WAY
WITHIN THE CANNABIS. INDUSTRY
THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT IS OF
SIGNIFICANTLY HINDERING AND
TURNING OUR LEGAL MARKET PLACE.
I SEE THIS INDUSTRY IS BEING AN
IMPORTANT INDUSTRY FOR A LONG
TERM ESPECIALLY AS WE MOVE INTO
OUR MISSION. IS A GREAT THAT
FOR THE TAKEN I. APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RING YES TO US
RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT. THANK
YOU MISTER CALDERON BEING IN
HEARING OUT. UNDER IS RUBIO
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR OPEN
THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS TO THEIR A- ON MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF A. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THERE I
SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS A
RETAINER VIOLATED SEVENTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL REACH SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
ACKERMAN TRANSPORTATION OF
MAKING RACIAL FOR. MISTER ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THE BETTER
SPEAKER AB TWO FIVE IS AN
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE BILL AND IN LIGHT OF
COMET NINETEEN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
CONSOLIDATED SEVERAL NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILLS. AND MINOR
MEASURES TO A SINK. TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY FIVE. HAS UNANIMOUS THE
AND OPPOSITION OF I RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR FRASER HEARING
THERE FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IN
THERE TO VOTE. PAUL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TWO THIRDS VOTE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT IS I
SIXTEEN OH ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM EIGHTY MILLION I LIVE AT
ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
BILL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SOME THE RIVER CARILLO
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE HEALING
ARTS. WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN. ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO MOVING TO. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RESEARCH IN
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE COSMETICS.
THIRTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. THE. THIS BILL IS
THE TOXICS FREE COSMETICS ACT
THIS BILL WILL BAN COSMETICS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY CONTAIN TWELVE
TOXIC CHEMICALS KNOWN AND
ESTABLISHED BY SCIENCE TO CAUSE
CANCER REPRODUCTIVE HARM
HORMONE DISRUPTION IN OVERALL
AFFECTED SUPPRESSED IMMUNE
SYSTEM WHICH MAKES THE
NECESSARY DURING THIS COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE SCIENCE
IS CLEAR ON THE HARMFUL NATURE
OF THESE CHEMICALS COSMETICS
CONTAINING BEES TWELVE
CHEMICALS ARE ARE READY BANNED
IN THE EUROPEAN UNION.
CALIFORNIA COULD SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THE SAME TOXIC FREE
COSMETICS AS THOSE ALREADY
BEING SOLD IN EUROPE AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD WITH SIMILAR
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. THE
INDUSTRY AFTER TWO YEARS OF
WORK AND NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS ON
THIS BILL. THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL HAS COME
AROUND FROM A STRONG OPPOSED TO
A SUPPORT ON THIS PRINCIPLE AT.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS SHOULD BE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE GLOBAL
STANDARD F. DEFINED BY THE
EUROPEAN UNION. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MURATSUCHI SEEING AND HEARING
THERE FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RAW. NUMBERS VERY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A- ON MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. RIGHT.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES WE
WILL MOVE BACK UP IN FILE ORDER
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FORCE. BY SOME MEMBER
RIO ANOTHER'S IMMACULATE
HITTING OURS. THIS CAREER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT DIRECTS THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD. ON A-
OF INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL GRAB
BY JACK VERY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE AN INCREASE SHORTAGE
OF PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
WHICH IS ONLY EXPECTED TO
INCREASE WITH AN AGING
POPULATION AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT WAS A PRE COLD AT
NIGHT THE ISSUE THAT HAS ONLY
FURTHER INTENSIFIED THE
SHORTAGE FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES LACK THE
MOST ACCESS TO MEDICAL SERVICES
AND ARE EXPERIENCING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AT ALARMING RATES.
LET ME KNOW POSITIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
SPANISH SPEAKING POPULATION.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS SPANISH
SPEAKING POSITIONS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT PAGE. THE BILL HAS
THE BIPARTISAN WRITTEN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF A- ON
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FIFTY SEVEN NEWS HERE
THE MEASUREPASSES MOVING BACK
DOWN IF I ORDERED A FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT OH
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT OH
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
ANOTHER SNACK LATER
CONSERVATION MISTER MILLER. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THEY MESSED
FIGURE MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT
OR NOT WAS INTRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT OF MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
THE MADE SIGNIFICANT
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
REFORM IMPROVE. THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSIONS
OPERATIONS BE CDC. AS BANK AS
BACKGROUND STARTING IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MINOR THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICES RECEIVE NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDER COMPLAINTS ABOUT
HOW BE CDC WAS APPROACHING
ENFORCEMENT. OF ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS OF ITS PERMITS AFTER
FURTHER INVESTIGATION EFFORTS
DID NOT YIELD RESULTS I WAS
JOINED BY A BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
LEGISLATORS. AND COOPER OF THIS
BILL TO REQUEST THE STATE AUDIT
THE ADIT REPORT RELEASED IN
MAY TWENTY NINTH IN CONFIRM
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CDC'S. ENFORCEMENT STRATEGY.
ALSO REVEALED MANY OF FISH AND
SEE IF THE ORGANIZATIONS
OPERATIONS THE AUTHOR HAD
NUMEROUS RECOMMENDATIONS THE
CDC WITH. UP THE CITY STAFF IS
ALREADY IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE LARGEST
THAT FORM THE BASIS FOR THE
BILL BILL PASSED OF NATURAL.
WITH UNANIMOUS BY. AS MY VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
AT THE SPEAKER PRO TEM OTHER
ITEMS TODAY WHICHIS FILE ITEM
ONE HUNDRED AB. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE. THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME BILL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN ACCOLADE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS CLIMATE CHANGE
IS ALREADY AFFECTING CALIFORNIA
IS PROJECTED TO CONTINUE TO DO
SO WELL INTO THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. MANY IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WILL VERY BASED ON A
COMMUNITIES PHYSICAL SOCIAL AND
ACT ECONOMIC CHARACTERISTICS
WHICH TEND TO EXTEND BEYOND
CITY OR COUNTY BOUNDARIES. THIS
MAKES READ FOR NAY BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY
BASED OR- IS NONPROFITS AND
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES VITAL.
RESULT THANK. THE GUN THE PER
TO PREPARING FOR THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE HOWEVER MANY ENTITIES
NOT YET BEGUN CORD THIS FOR.
WITH JASON AND IN THEIR REACH
AND SAW HAVE NOT BEEN PLANNING
A ALL. DUE TO LACK OF CORE
PLANNING THE STATE'S CURRENT
MECHANISM FOR FUNDING
ADAPTATION PROJECTS HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY MALE WITH NO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS BEST. TO
ENSURE THE MOST AFFECT
RESILIENCY RETURN. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO FILL THIS GAP BY
DEVELOPING GUIDANCE FOR
POTENTIAL STATE FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE AND- DID READ PRICE.
SIX A- STATE. LOCAL A REGIONAL
ENTITIES TOOK. WHEN FOR CLIMATE
I. IN A WAY THAT PROMOTES
REGIONAL SOLUTIONS IMPROVE
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
ADAPTATION ACTIONS AND ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VERY DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE FIVE FIFTY TWO KNOWS
THEY'VE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO FILE ORDER FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY SOME A
MEMBER DAVID CHIU ANOTHER SNACK
LATER FIREARMS DAVID CHIU
YOU'LL BE NICE. THANK YOU
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY
FORTY AND WITH STRENGTHEN OUR
STATES ON HANDGUN ACT IN TWO
WAYS. FIRST IT WOULD ASSIST
LAUNCH SOLVING GUN RELATED
CRIMES. MY CRISTINA BEING IS A
CRIME SOLVING TOOL THAT
IMPRINTS A STAMP ON A BULLET
CASING WHEN A GUN IS FIRED. ON
FORSMAN TO LINK CASES THAT GOT.
THIS EASE MANY FOR PERFORMANCE
MICRO AND IN SENT MANY. TO
PRODUCE GUNS WERE THE KNOWLEDGE.
I CAN THE ORDER REDUCE. UNDER
THREES BY INSURING THAT.
FIREARM SOLD IN OUR STATE HAS A
KING LOAD INDICATOR TO SIGNAL
ONE OF. IS AND- DISCONNECT
MAKING. TO PREVENT A FIRE FROM.
THE BIG TO PREVENT A FROM FAR.
WHEN EIGHTY MAY IS A- THIS IS A
CALL SENSE SAFETY PROPOSAL AND
I RESPECT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE AND
HEARING NO FOR DEBATE THE
MATTER OF A WILL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR A- ON MEMBERS
VOTED THE. ALL MEMBERS. BURKE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE I FORTY NEWS THEM AT
PASSES. FILE EIGHTY SIX AB TWO
NINE THAT WILL READ. SOME
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SIMPLY GIVES
ANOTHER ACTUALLY SHELTERS IT'S
A GOOD THING YOU ARE. THANK YOU
VERY MADAM SO AND MADAMS. AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT IS
THE BILL TO NINES. ONE BRING
OUT TO POINTS THIS BILL WAS TO
GIVE CITIES AND COUNTIES WITH
SHOP CRY. DECK INS. LIKE THE
BILL TO ECSTATIC SHE IN
EXISTING. TO REQUIRE THOSE
PLANS TO BE APPROVED BY THE
FARM. UTILIZATION I RESPECT ASK
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
GET SEVEN SEEING HEARING NO
DEBATE ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS THE
VERY VOTE. ON MEMBERS OF THE
WHO DESIRE TO. OUR MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO BOTH. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE I SIXTEEN KNOWS
ONE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TO. NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER ANOTHER'S
NEGLIGENCE. DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO PRESENT YOU
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO WOULD
SEEKS TO EXPAND EXISTING
PROTECTIVELY. TO VICTIMS OF ANY
CRIME ALSO TO ME FAMILY MEMBERS
OF HOMICIDE VICTIMS. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO DOES NOT MAKE
ANY CHANGES IN THE AMOUNT OF
LEAD CURRENTLY AVAILABLE. IT
ONLY EXPANDS THESE PROTECTIONS
TO INDIVIDUAL GROUPS OF VICTIM.
OF CRIME THIS WILL CREATE THIS
HAVEN FOR SURVIVORS WHO ME I TO
RECOVER AND TO GIVE SAFETY AND-
FROM. WITHOUT THE OF LOSING
THEIR JOB. THIS BILL HAS
REACHED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO NO. QUICKLY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERT A ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALENT
I SIXTY YOU KNOW THEY'RE THE
MEASURE PASSES WITH PAT RILEY
EIGHTY EIGHT IN EIGHT NINE TO
BUY ITEM NINE AB THIRTY ONE ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
MIDDLE THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER WEBER ANOTHER
POLICE GOVERNMENT EVERY ARE
GONNA THINK. ADAM SPEAK. EYES
THANK YOU AB ONE TWO. ON WHICH
IS THE ONE PRIORITY FOR THE-
PLAY THE BLACK CAUCUS AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY WHAT IS THE FOR TO
STAY IN THE BILL REPARATION FOR
AFRICAN. IN CAL. THIS BILL
WOULD THE FORCE CONSISTS OF
EIGHT OF MA'AM. INCLUDE AND THE
PREVAILING RECORDS A BLACK
SLAVERY AND IT'S A LINGERING
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA CRAWL IN
STATES. PRIVATE WAS IN AMONG
OTHER THINGS. READ YOUR AS A
TEN THE CALIFORNIA'S ROLE MEANS
ONE OF PEOPLE AND THEIR AND
THEY'RE A LIFE BETWEEN CAL
STATE IN NINE FIFTY IN THE IN
THE SLAVERY SIX FIVE CALIFORNIA
WAS FOR STATE IN NAY ONLY MOST
OF WOULD MEET THIS. IS ACTIVELY
SO LACK OF SLEEP WHEN IN A WAY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA. OUR RIGHTS
SO THAT VOTERS TO HOLD PERSON
BONDED SO LONG AS THEY HAVE.
THEIR INTO THE STATE WITH THEIR
IN SLOW PROPERTY PRICES LATE
BUT IT EIGHTEEN FIFTY. CAL
QUARTERPER SAME TO WHO DO TO
X. THE BY OF SLAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND EIGHTY FIFTY
TWO CAL TO ADOPTED A HARSH.
SLAVE. IT'S AS IN THE HISTORIC
CASE OF ARCHIE LEE RETURNED TO
THEIR IN SLAVER'S IN DIRECT
VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION. UNTIL THE END OF
THE U. S. CIVIL WAR CALIFORNIA
CITY AND COUNTY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES AND FORCED A BOGUS
CONTRACT LABOR SYSTEM ALLOWING
SLAVEHOLDERS TO EFFECTIVELY
HOLE PERSONS IN BONDS BY IT. IN
A WORDS. COUNTY AND CITY OF
ACTIVELY INSTITUTIONAL BLACK
SLAVERY BOTH WITHIN AND BEYOND
CALIFORNIA THIS IS THE IS NOT
PART OF. EXCUSE ME OF THE STATE
BOOK WRITTEN WITH CONCRETE
EXAMPLES OF CALIFORNIA
COMPLICITY IN RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN FACT THE
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES OF THE
PAST ECHO INTO THE EVERYDAY
LIVES OF TODAY'S CALIFORNIANS
ACCORDING STUBBORNNESS SOME
TWENTY TWENTY STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS BLACK MAKE UP
PERCENT CALIFORNIA'S. 43% ISN'T.
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT BY THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALES ACCOUNTS
A TWENTY EIGHT POINT 5% OF THE
STATE'S MALE PRISON POPULATION
IS THE FACT THAT BLACK. 20% OF
THE STATE MALES A RECENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
STATE THE BY NEARLY EVERY STATE
MEASURE BLACK EIGHTEEN TWELVE
STUDENTS HAVE A LOS PERFORMANCE
OF ANY RACIAL. GROUP IN. IT BUT
THE NEED IS THE- BUT NINETEEN
IS HAD A LIGHT ON COMBINATION
OF THESE PROCESS IS. EMERGING
DATA CONFIRMS A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
ILLNESS AND DEATH DUE TO
POVERTY TEEN FALL ON THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. IN SOME OF THE AGE
OF ENSLAVEMENT BOTH OF. AN
IMPOSSIBLE BIRTH A LEGACY OF
RACIAL HARM IN THE NFL THAT
COULD THAT CONTINUES TO IMPACT
THE CONDITIONS OF BLACK PEOPLE
AND BLACK LIFE IN CALIFORNIA.
EVIL'S JUST INJURIES LOSSES THE
BILL. BECAUSE UP I'M NOT ECHO
THAT. BY TWO. AB TWO TWENTY AND
SAM NATION IMPACT SLAVERY IS
AFTER LIVES AND PROVIDE THE FOR
DEVELOP A GUIDELINES HOW TO
BEGIN ADDRESS DESPAIR WI FI AND
STRIP. MEMBERS ARE CORRECTLY AT
FOR YOUR VOTE ESTABLISHMENT THE
THIS THIS PARTICULAR. TASK
FORCE TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF
REPARATIONS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER MISTER THIRTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LIKE TO-
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE A SHARE THE
EXPERIENCE IN THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY RELATED. TO
THE COMMISSION TO- EVALUATE
THE- THEIR HISTORY AND TO
EVALUATE THE IDEA OF
REPARATIONS. THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN EXIT A COMMUNITY HAD-
ITS OWN EXPERIENCE WHEN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS ESTABLISHED THE
COMMISSION ON WARTIME
RELOCATION AND INTERNMENT OF
CIVILIANS. THAT LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR. THE NOT ONLY
THE REPARATIONS THAT WERE PAID
TO THE OVER A HUNDRED. THOUSAND
JAPANESE BECAUSE THEY WERE
INTERNED DURING WORLD WAR TWO
BUT PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
PROVIDED A FORUM A PUBLIC FOR A
NATION WIDE PUBLIC FORUM. TO
FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. ENGAGED AND- I'M A
STATION ABOUT THE IMPORTANT
ISSUES OF AT THAT ARE WRITTEN
TO BE RAISED- BY BY THIS
PROPOSAL AND SO- I WANTED TO
ACT AT. ALL MY FULL SUPPORT FOR
THIS- PROPOSAL BASED ON THE-
EXPERIENCE OF THE CAN MORE TIME
LOCATION- FOR THE- MEETING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
DOCTOR RIVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. AS STATED BEFORE THIS
BILL DOES NOT TAKE A POSITION
ON THE ON THE REPARATIONS
SHOULD TAKE. BUT DOES TAKE A
CLEAR POSITION ON REPARATIONS
IS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS A
PERSISTENT EFFECTS OF SLAVERY
AND ITS SUCCESSORS INCLUDING
JIM CROW SHARECROPPING.
REDLINING DEPT OF LABOR WEALTH
AND CAPITAL OVER IN CARSON.
OVER POLICING AND SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION. IN THE PAST WE
HAD IDEAS RIVAS ROMS THROUGH
REPARATIONS NATIVE AMERICANS
WITH THE THEFT OF THEIR LAND
JAPANESE SUBMIT. UNDER TERM IN
THE- TO A- YOU. WE IS FOR THE
HOLOCAUST. IT'S NOT IT. THAT
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN TREATED
UNDER NEED THE NAME TO MAKE THE
HOLD TO MAKE UP FOR THE LOSSES
THE EXPERIENCE TO CATCH UP TO
THE REST OF SOCIETY THIS IS WE
REALLY REALIZE IS IMPORTANT
EXCEPT FOR EVERY EVERYONE EXT
THE AFRICAN AMERICANS THE ONE
OF. REYES AFTER SO FOR THE
PROMISE OF FORTY ACRES AND A
MULE RIVER AFTER HIS DEATH
PLAYS INTO THE WORKING AND OF
THE OWNERS WELL REP. WE PLAYED
FOR THE LOSS OF THEIR SLATE AT
EARLY CALIFORNIA WAS IN FACT AN
IN LAW COMPLETE COMPLEX IN
ENABLING SLAVERY WITHIN ITS
BORDERS THIS DEMO THIS REPORT
MP OF THE AMERICAN ONLY THE
BEST LADIES AND REMINDED THAT
WE HAVE A RECORD I'D A
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO GRANT
HARDSHIP AND JUSTICE I RESPECT.
BOTH EIGHT TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN AT ALL.
THE LONG MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE
A. ALL ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
THEIR TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THOSE EYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE. THE FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
WE WILL TWENTY FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
pAND OTHERS NOT FROM POINT.
MYSTERY OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER-
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT THIS BILL SENATE BILL
TWO ZERO FOUR THREE. WHICH
ADDRESSES. NO SAFETY AND HEALTH
OF OUR STATE AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS- MISS THIS OCTOBER
NINETEEN HEALTH CRISIS WERE
UNDER. EVERY DAY FOR THE CROSS
OUR STATE RISE EARLY. LEAVING
BEHIND THEIR FAMILIES TO PACK
IN CROWDED. THE BUSES THEY WORK
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER IN THE
FIELDS. THEIR DAYS ARE LONG
ONES. THE WORK THEY DO IS HARD.
IT BREAKS DOWN THE BODY OVER
TIME MY GRANDFATHER WHO RAISED
ME THE FARM WORKER. AND I SAW
HOW HARD. HE WORKED FOR FIFTY
YEARS OF HIS LIFE AS A FARM
WORKER. DID THIS WORK DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. AND HE DID IT FOR
BARELY ENOUGH MONEY TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. AND IS NOW MANY
FARMWORKERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
HERE CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
UNITED STATES. THEY LACK ACCESS
TO THE HEALTH CARE THAT MANY OF
US TAKE FOR GRANTED.
UNFORTUNATELY CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS. AMONG FARMWORKERS
ARE VERY VERY COMMON. AND
VIRUSES VIRUSES CAN SPREAD
QUICKLY. YOU SEE IT'S NOT JUST
THAT FARMWORKERS WORKING CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO EACH OTHER. IS
THAT THEY HANDLE THAT YOU KNOW
THE SAME EQUIPMENT AND- THE
TRACTORS IN THE MACHINES THAT
THEY USE BUT THEY ALSO LIVE IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO ONE ANOTHER.
AT LEAST ONE APARTMENT OR A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME WHERE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
SUBLET ROOMS GARAGES SHEDS
WHATEVER SPACE IS MADE
AVAILABLE. HERE THE GOAL OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IF SOMEONE
GETS SICK IT'S HARD TO KEEP
THEM SEPARATED CAN'T SHELTER IN
PLACE THE CAT SOCIAL DISTANCE.
AND AS LONG AS THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES OUR FARMWORKERS ARE
AT RISK AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MORAL DUTY TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER
OTHER FOOD RELATED INDUSTRIES.
A COVERT NINETEEN OUTBREAK IN
OUR FARM WORKER. POPULATIONS IN
OUR OUT COMMUNITIES THEY WOULD
THREATEN OUR FOOD SUPPLY NOT
ONLY OUR STATE FOOD SUPPLY OUR
NATIONAL FOOD SUPPLY. FARMERS I
THERE ARE PARTNERS IN THIS
EFFORT. MOST OF THEM UNDERSTAND
THE RISK THAT THEIR WORKERS
THAT FARM WORKERS FACE EVERY
SINGLE DAY THEY CARE ABOUT
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THEY WANT
TO KEEP THEM SAFE. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT OUR STATE OUR COUNTRY
WE WERE CLEARLY UNPREPARED TO
HANDLE THE HISTORIC. PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING. AND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A PATCHWORK OF SAFETY
GUIDANCE ACROSS OUR STATE. AND
SUCH GUIDES CAN BE DIFFERENT
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY. AND IT'S
NOT ALWAYS CLEAR OR
STANDARDIZED AND SO THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO CREATE A CLEAR
UNIFORM STANDARD. THAT APPLIES
TO ALL AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'LL MAKE THINGS
EASIER FOR FARMERS WANT TO
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES. IT'LL
KEEP FARMWORKERS SAFEWHICH IS
IN EVERYONE'S BEST INTEREST. WE
SHOULD BE MAKING THE SAFETY
THESE GUYS DECISIONS ON A
COUNTY BY COUNTY LEVEL IT'S TOO
INCONSISTENT TWO ONE EVEN IT'S
TOO COMPLICATED FOR FARMERS AND
IT LEAVES TOO MANY FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK. WE
NEED A SINGLE A BUS AT.
GUIDELINES TO PROTECT
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS FROM COLD
IN NINETEEN. THIS LEGISLATION
IT DOES THAT BY ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE IN THREE WAYS FIRST. IT
REQUIRES AT AND CAL OSHA ARE
THE ESTABLISH AT THE END.
EXCUSE ME THE DECEPTICON THEN
SAFETY GUIDELINES FOR
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYEES. I LIVE
ON THEIR OWN ARE NOT
ENFORCEABLE. AND SO SECOND THE
BILL ALSO DIRECTS CAL OSHA
STANDARDS BOARD TO ADOPT
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS FOR KOBE NINETEEN
INFECTION PREVENTION STANDARDS
THAT CAN BE ENFORCED THIRTY
SECONDS BUT STANDARDS ONE CLUE
BUT NOT LIMITED TO SANITATION
PRACTICES PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND PHYSICAL DISS THE
REQUIREMENTS. AND THIRD THIS
BILL IMPLEMENTS A PART OUT
REACH CAMP IN TO AGRICULTURE
WORKERS ON THESE BEST PRACTICES
TO STAY STATE IS STAY SAFE FROM
THE NINE. WE NEED. A STATE IN
THE COUNTRY IS THAT OKAY DEEMED
FORMER AS ESSENTIAL WE'VE SEEN
A PATCHWORK OF AGRICULTURE
WORKPLACE SAFETY DEPENDS ON OUR
STATE. WHAT THIS BILL IS ASKING
FOR IS IT MUCH. MANY FARMERS
HAVE BEEN GIVEN LITTLE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES IN SOME
AREAS OF THE STATE THE PLAN TO
KEEP FARMWORKERS SAY SAY IT IS
UNCLEAR. EMERGENCY STANDARD
WHAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE NOW BEFORE FARMWORKERS
GETS SICK IN OUR FOOD SUPPLY IS
THREATENED. WE MUST ALSO STAY
CLEAR EYED ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO HERE TO PROTECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FARMWORKERS THE
CENTRAL WORKERS WHO HAVE PUT
THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE FOR ALL
OF US SO WE COULD KEEP FOOD.
TABLE DURING THIS PENDANT.
BILLS ALL. THANKYOU. PETER WAS
BUT- THANK YOU. MR GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN. FULL SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE AND I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE. FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. YOU KNOW YOU'VE
HEARD ME SPEAK. SEVERAL TIMES A
ABOUT THE REGION THAT I
REPRESENT IMPERIAL COUNTY COULD
TELL A VALLEY. LARGELY
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY- BASED
ECONOMY. AND YOU'VE ALSO HEARD
ME TALK ABOUT THE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES THAT EXIST
IN THAT REGION THE HIGHEST IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. REPORT
THIS CAME OUT WE ARE NOW AT 26%
IN LIKELY WHEN WE HAVE OUR
HANDS AROUND. THE WE GOV HE
ECONOMY SHUT DOWN WILL PROBABLY
BE CLOSER TO THE 3540%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. AND JUST
RECENTLY. THE REGION WAS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED. WITH THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF PER CAPITA POSITIVE
COVERT NINETEEN CASES THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE CASES
CONSISTING OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IN OUR REGION MAJORITY OF THOSE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS BEING
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
INDIVIDUALS WHO IF YOU LIVE IN
PER COUNTY- CROSSING THE BORDER
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE FOOD ON
OUR TABLES IN OUR GROCERY
STORES AND SUPPLYING THE LONG.
CHAIN OF FOOD SUPPLY THAT EIST
IN OUR- LOW COUNTRY AND OF
COURSE IN OUR STATE. AND MAKING
SURE THAT THAT ISN'T
INTERRUPTED- NOT ONLY TO HAVE
AN IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY BUT AN
IMPACT ON THE CONFERENCE. THAT
WE ALL HAVE WHEN WE GET UP ARE
ABLE TO GO TO THE GROCERY STORE
TO BUY THE THINGS THAT WE NEED.
THE DENTAL FOR EVERY. OUR LIVES.
WHAT THE IN HERE IN THE HAVE
ALL POLL INCLUDING MY FOR
TRYING TO IS THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING AGRICULTURE. THE
FOOD AND SAFETY COMPONENT OF
THE FOOD SUPPLY. AND WE KNOW
THAT IF WE PROTECT THE WORKERS.
WE ACCOMPLISHED ALL THE LIVES
AS WELL. AND SO IT IS A MODEST
ASK TO HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
AGENCIES WORKING WITH OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES. TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF THE
SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE THE
PROTECTIONS ON FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE DOING THE- ULTIMATE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE. A HEALTHY
WORKFORCE. CONTRIBUTING TO THE
OVERALL ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF
OUR STATE. ROOM THE RECALL
CAROL WORK THAT HAPPENS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SOMEONE THANK
THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD. AND THAT
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
CULTURAL PARTNERS TO CONTINUE
TO PROMOTE HEALTHY SAFE. FOR
YOUR- IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU MR GARCIA MISTER
FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER YOUR HAND-
IT'S ALWAYS AWKWARD TO STAY IN
OPPOSITION TO A COLLEAGUE THE
CHIPS BACKED SO. STANDING BUT
IS IT OKAY TO COME OUT OF THE
CREE IN AG. SOMEBODY WHO'S MAY
IS STILL IN AG. WE JUST ALL
KOBE NINETEEN AND WE REALIZE
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL SOMETIMES IS
ALWAYS THE BEST POLICY THE
STATE IS SO DIVERSE SO UNIQUELY
DIVERSE AND ARE AT AGRICULTURE
READ ARE UNIQUELY DIVERSE AS
WELL YOU GO FROM CROPS TO. WITH
IT WELL WE PLUS PIECE OF FRUIT
PRODUCE WAS TYPES OF. AND WE
START BROAD BROUGH. LIKE BUILD
ARM IS DOING RIGHT NOW AND I
ALSO HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN
YOU- AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
I CAN CAN YOU TO. WORK AWESOME
WHAT. SAY THE- ECONOMY THE CA.
THAT WE- WIDE UMBRELLA AND
ACTUALLY CONCERNS ME A LITTLE
BIT AND THAT IS MY BIGGEST FEAR
WITH THIS BILL IS I DO BELIEVE
WE NEED IT TO BE MORE LOCALIZED
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL REGIONS
COULD MORE CONTROL OVER THEIR
INABILITY COME UP. BECAUSE THEY
TO KNOW. HELLO WHAT IS BAD.
COMMUNITY BY ABSOLUTELY APPLIED
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
IN IN IN CONCEPT I'M VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT I JUST THIS
THIS WHITE APPROACH HAS DEEPLY
CONCERNED SO I RESPECTFULLY
HAPPEN JUST SOME OF THOSE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR BEING A-
AU FOR. THE ON THE MATTER THREE
THIS WOULD YOU LIKE. SURE AND I
IN SOME APPRECIATE. THOSE
COMMENTS. NO WHAT STEVE BALL
TAKEN IN. YOU KNOW I DO HAVE TO
MENTION I HAVE WORKED ITS-
AGRICULTURE STATE THERE'S AND I
THE ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HERE
THAT- THAT WORK WILL CONTINUE.
CERTAINLY BILL THESE. FOR EVERY
ONE YOU KNOW THAT POINT IS VERY
WELL TAKE THIS IS. DIVERSE
STATE. A DIFFERENT STATE BUT
REGION AND BY OUR DISTRICTS BUT
AGAIN WE MUST ALSO STAY VERY
CLEAR EYED ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO HERE AND THAT'S TO
PROTECT OUR PHONE MINE. SO
WORKERS SURE THAT OUR INDUSTRY
IS AGRICULTURE JUST RECOVERING
REMAINS A VIABLE AND
PRODUCTIVE- AND SO CERTAINLY-
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE WANT A
EVERYONE WITH. SO WITH THAT.
ASPECT THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELL
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE- HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES. MISTER
CALDERON FOR WHAT REASON DO YOU
RISE. I HAVE A MOTION YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER TO TAKE
HAVE AS H. R. NINETY SEVEN
TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE THE PURPOSE OF IT. WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO BE THE ORDER. YEAH
WE WILL TAKE UP THE- ITEM
WITHOUT. WE WILL TAKE AT THE
ITEM THAT REFERENCE FILE HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE RAIL MISTER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. MEMBERS PRESENT
HR NINETY SEVEN RELATED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HIGH SPEED
RAIL BUSINESS PLAN. HR NINETY
SEVEN RE DIRECTS THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY TO HOLD OFF ON
ENTERING INTO MAJOR CONTRACTS
AND TO LEGISLATURE CAN WEIGH IN
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATION OF
BOND FUNDS. THE AUTHORITY
STATES IN ITS DRAFT AND THAT IT
PLANS TO ENTER INTO TWO MAJOR
ACTS THIS FALL. ONE SIGN THESE
CONTRACTS WILL PRECLUDE ANY
DISCUSSION FOR ANY ALTERNATIVE
PROJECT DIRECTION OF THE
AUTHORITY GOES. ESSENTIALLY
ONCE THESE CONTRACTS ARE LET
THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE ON THE
HOOK FOR FIFTEEN SESSIONS GOING
DOWN THE ROAD. AND LEFT OUT OF
THE CONVERSATION ENTIRELY. BUT
WE WILL STILL BE ASKED TO PAY
FOR IT. I PERSONALLY HAVE LOST
ALL CONFIDENCE IN THIS GROUP TO
DEVELOP AND DELIVER WHAT THEY
PROMISE. EVERY BUSINESS PLAN
HAS BEEN MORE COSTLY AND LESS
SCOPE OFFERED. BERMAN
INCONSISTENT COST ESTIMATES TO
IMPOSSIBLE PROJECT SCHEDULES
THEY PROVIDE FICTIONAL
RIDERSHIP EXPECTATION AND
EXAGGERATED BENEFITS. THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED NEARLY ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN CHANGE
ORDERS AND WHO HAS BENEFITS NOT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
SPENT ON CONSULTANTS. THE WAY
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN MANAGED
IS EMBARRASSING TO SAY THE
LEAST AND NOW THEY WANT US WANT
TO FORCE US TO DOUBLE DOWN BY
AWARDING CONTRACTS BEFORE WE
SEE THE LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATE
THE FUNDS FOR THEM. THIS IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. REGARDLESS
OF HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL THIS RESOLUTION
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THE
ASSEMBLY WILL NOT BE SUPPORT OF
ANY DEPARTMENT TRYING TO USE
THESE TACTICS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. TAKING CARE
MR FUNG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY AS A CO AUTHOR OF HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN.
MEMBERS WE FACE A CRUCIAL
JUNCTURE WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL.
TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY SIGN THESE MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR CON CONSTRUCTING
TRACKS WITHOUT FIRST ALLOWING
THE LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE ITS
FUNDING WE WILL ESSENTIALLY
HAVE OUR HANDS TIED. WE MUST
NOT PERMIT UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS TO MAKE THIS
DECISION IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE STEWARDS
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS BECAUSE IT
IS NOT OUR MONEY IS THE MONEY
OF HARD WORKING CALIFORNIA.
SOMETHING THAT WE MUST ALWAYS
BINDER OFFICE WE HAVE SEEN OVER
AND OVER AGAIN ALL THE REASONS
WHY WE MUST STOP FUNDING THIS
MESS MISMANAGED FLAWED AND
NEVER ENDING PROJECT WE SHOULD
HAVE HALTED THIS PROJECT A LONG
TIME AGO. BUT IS EVEN MORE
GLARING AND LOT OF OUR MASSIVE
BUDGET DEFICIT AND THE THREAT
OF CUTS TO EDUCATION AND HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS. WE SHOULD NOT
FINALLY SUPPORT CONTINUING THIS
PROJECT. THE WORST THING WE CAN
DO RIGHT NOW IS LOCK OURSELVES
INTO MULTIPLE THIRTY YEAR
CONTRACTS. THIS WOULD BE THE
HEIGHT OF IRRESPONSIBILITY FOR
THE EXECUTION. ARE WE PREPARED
TO PRIORITIZE THIS MISMANAGED
PROJECT OVER ALL OF THE
COUNTLESS PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
THAT SLATED TO BE CUT IN OUR
BUDGET. HOW CAN WE PRIOR TO
THIS TRAIN OVER PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT FIRST RESPONDERS HELP
TEACHERS EDUCATE FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND PROVIDE DOCTORS
THE EQUIPMENT AND FUNDING TO
HELP SAVE LIVES IN OUR STATE.
TO ME THAT'S UNTHINKABLE. TO
THAT END I THANK CHAIRMAN
FRAZIER FOR IT INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION THAT WILL HELP
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION OF
THE MERITS OF THIS PROJECT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. ABOUT. THANK
YOU MISTER FONG MS RIVAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY SEVEN I
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THIS
YEAR THAT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED.
SPEED RAIL OF. THE VALUE IT ALL
BUT IT IS TO THE CURRENT
APPROACH TO CONSTRUCTION GIVING
GIVEN THE COST OVER RUNS
CHANGED IN TIMELINE. I HELD
THAT LEGISLATION THIS YEAR.
RESULT COMMITMENTS THAT I
RECEIVED FROM THE AUTHORITY TO
ENGAGE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY THIS BODY. I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE A
FORTY GAUGE WITH ALL OF US HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY MOST OF US NONE
OF US WERE HERE TO VOTE. ON IN
THE PAST ON THIS BOND AND WE
NEXT YEAR OUR DECISION TO-
APPROPRIATE. BOND FUNDS AND WE
WILL ALL NEED TO MAKE THAT
DECISION TOGETHER SO I THINK
IT'S A PORTENT TO STARTING GATE
WITH US HEY. CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH. I GET IT DEFICIT. I
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE AUTHORITY
TO ENTER INTO LONG TERM
CONTRACTS UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE
HAS HAD A CHANCE TO WAY YET. I
BELIEVE WE MUST BE TOPPLING
CAUTIOUS WITH OUR LIMITED FUNDS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORITY MY
COLLEAGUES- AND- IT IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME. I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER DO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION. THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM WE HAVE BEFORE US
TODAY IS IMMENSELY DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT WAS PROMISED TO
VOTERS TWELVE YEARS AGO. JUST
IN THE PROMISED TO BRING
BENEFITS TO VARIOUS REGIONS BY
CONNECTING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
POPULATION HERBS TO THOSE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. HAS
FALLEN. DRAMATICALLY AND SADLY
SHORT. COLLEAGUES IS RESOLUTION
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
GAINING BACK OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT BEFORE KEY
DECISIONS ARE MADE ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THIS PROJECT. WE OWE
IT TO THE RESIDENTS OF OUR
STATE PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
THOUGHT CONSIDERATION PROJECT
ALTERNATIVES. SO THAT
EVENTUALLY. ALL CALIFORNIANS
WAS MAY SEE THE BENEFITS FROM
HIGH SPEED RAIL I RESPECT
WESTERN TYPE OF. IF YOU'RE WE
ARE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I RISE
AS A PROUD COOPER OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT BEFORE
US THE DRAFT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY VISIT REQUIRES HIS
BODY THREE BILLION. DOLLARS TO
THIS PROJECT THEY WERE HIGHER
THIS AT A TIME WHEN WE RE
DEBATING CUTS TO EDUCATION
HEALTH CARE SENIOR. AND OTHER.
THINGS THAT NOT WANT TO TOUCH.
MEANWHILE THE SPEED RAIL PRETTY
IS CONTINUE TO BALLOON COSTS
WHAT THE SAME TIME LET. GO OF
THE PROJECT THE DRAFT PLAN LACK
DETAILS. LACKS OVERSIGHT OF IF
THE- TO CONNECT OUR STATE IN AN
ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY MEANINGFUL WAY.
THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS YET TO
BE ANSWERED IN THIS BUSINESS
PLAN THESE QUESTIONS ARE AS
BROAD AS HOW MANY WRITERS WILL
THIS TRAIN HAVE AND HOW MUCH
WILL IT COST. WRITERS I. WILL
AND RELY TRANSFER. AND I AM A
HUGE BELIEVER IN CLEAN RAIL
PROJECTS THAT EXTEND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS TO ALL CORNERS OF THE
STATE. BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A
CLEAR AND THOUGHT A PLAN TO
CONNECT THE CENTRAL. JOBS AND
TING. DEVELOP TO THOSE AREAS
THIS PLAN DOESN'T ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED ANY OF THESE ISSUES.
AND IT ISN'T. BEING EXECUTED IN
A WAY THAT IS MEANINGFUL AND IS
TRUE TO WHAT THE VOTERS ASKED
TO DO. MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
CALIFORNIANS DON'T FOR THIS
PROJECT AND WE SHOULD NOT. TO
OPERATE IT THE WAY IT IS GOING
AND FOR THIS REASON TO ASK FOR
THE- THANK. OKAY YOUR. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT JUST FOR
US TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT A UNIQUE
MOMENT THIS IS IN THE
LEGISLATURE A MOMENT WHEN BOTH
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN MEMBERS
WHEN MEMBERS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS ARE
SUPPORTED BY HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT IN MEMBERS THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT ARE UNITED RIGHT NOW
AND ASK FOR ONE THING. WHICH IS
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE BE GIVEN.
THE TO EXERCISE ITS
RESPONSIBILITY. BODY TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT. OVER WHAT IS THE
LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
IN THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
NOT DOUBT HE- ARE ASKING FOR
THAT BUT THAT WE ARE DEMANDING
THAT THROUGH THIS RESOLUTION
THAT WE FOR FILL OUR DO. TO
WRAP. WAYS IS OF EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THEIR NEEDS
AND DESIRES AND HOPES FOR THIS
PROJECT THAT WE TAKE A MOMENT
TO. EXPAND THAT A PUBLIC AGENCY.
LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS AND
ADDRESS THEM FULLY AND
COMPREHENSIVELY. THAT WE NOW
TAKE A PAUSE TO LOOK AT THIS
PROJECT. WHICH STARTED SO MANY
YEARS AGO TO SAY BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH IT IN RESPONSE
MANNER HOW WE CONSIDERED. WHAT
HAS CHANGED STATE AND WHAT
CHANGE WITH REGARD TO THE
FINANCING OF THIS PROJECT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY DOLLAR
THAT. IS SPENT IN THE BEST
POSSIBLE WAY THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT ALTERNATIVE MOVING FORWARD.
AND INCORPORATING THAT INTO
THIS PROJECT MEMBERS MAKE NO
MISTAKE I REMAIN A SUPPORTER OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT BUT
I HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THIS PROJECT. BEING ROLLED OUT
IN THE STATE I HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
CREATE. STRANDED ASSETS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STATE BUT DOESN'T
OF WHAT'S PROP. TO THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LESS.
UNITIES BUT THAT TRAIN IS
PASSING THROUGH WE HAVE
PROMISED THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
THEIR ACCEPTANCE OF THIS
PROJECT. THEY WILL NOT HAVE
THAT IF THIS PROJECTIS NOT
COMPLETE IT INTO OUR POPULATION
CENTERS IN THE BAY AREA AND LOS
ANGELES REGION. IF THIS PROJECT
REMAINS. ONLY GOES FROM OUR
SIDE OF BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED.
THAT VALLEY IT'S NOT GOING TO
GET WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PROMISED IN TERMS OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES OR CLEANER AIR OR
RELIABLE IN THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THROUGHOUT THEIR
REGION. I AM VERY CONCERNED
THAT IF WE CONTINUE THE PATH OF
THIS PROJECT IT WILL NEVER BE
COMPLETED AND I SAY THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO SUPPORTS THE
PROJECT AND WANTS TO SEE IT
DONE IN A LIFETIME. SO WITH.
URGE YOU TO HAVE AN AYE VOTE ON
HR NINETY SEVEN SO THAT WE CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT WE DELIVER THE
PROMISED TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MISTER
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR CHAMBER. I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOD THE AUTHOR AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE CHAIR
FOR OFFERING THIS RESOLUTION
I'M HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND
WHAT I. REALLY APPRECIATE IS
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT HE SAYS THE
BUDGET. NEEDS TO CONSIDER FALL
OFF BECAUSE PERHAPS. THE
BIGGEST. FOR CLOSE TO THE
CONSIDERATION OF ALTERNATIVES
BEYOND THE UNFATHOMABLE ACTUAL
COST IN THE PARTICULARLY ACUTE
OPPORTUNITY COSTS NOT HAVE THIS
MASSIVE DEFICIT IS IT HAS TIED
US TO ONE PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY. I HAPPEN TO THINK
THAT THE FUTURE OF.
TRANSPORTATION IN A VERY
EXCITING I MEAN LOOKING AT A
COUPLE OF THE ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE OUT THERE YOU HAVE
PRIVATELY FUNDED HYPERLOOP
COMPANIES THAT REYES. IN THE-
YOUR IS IT IS THAT PLAN TO
ADAPT THEIR CITIES IN THE ROW
IN THEIR HIGH TO THE MATH DOT
ABOUT CONDOMS VEHICLES BUT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN DOING THAT
WORK SO MUCH OF OUR ATTENTION
FINANCE AND HAS BEEN ON TRYING
TO KEEP MOVING SB RIGHT. IN
THAT FUTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
HOW WE CAN ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE BEST VERSION OF
TOMORROW'S TECHNOLOGY I INSTEAD
OF THE WORST VERSION OF
YESTERDAY'S. THANK YOU MISTER
CREDIT PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK MEDI SPEAKER-
MEMBERS. WOW. WE TOGETHER HAVE
COME A LONG WAY. UP I
REPRESENTS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
FRESNO AND PARTICULARLY THE
MAYOR FOR EIGHT YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN RIPPED UP. AND WE HAVE
BEEN RIPPED OFF. RIPPED UP BY A
CITY AND A CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
THAT HAS CLOSE BUSINESSES
CLOSED STREETS THAT HAS PUT UP
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL CONCRETE- BUT
DOESN'T HAVE ANYWHERE NEAR THE
MONEY THE EVEN. ON BRAINS ALL
THE VERY TRACKS WE HAVE BEEN
THE WITNESS. OF PROMISES THAT
HAVE BEEN BROKEN. DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF FARMERS HAVE BEEN HAD
THEIR PROPERTY TAKEN AND RIPPED
UP AND THEY HAVE YET TO BE PAID.
THERE IS ONGOING LITIGATION
RIGHT NOW BY WOMEN OWNED
MINORITY OWNED COMPANIES THAT
SAID. THERE'S A PROMISE HERE
WE'RE GOING TO ORGANIZE OUR
PARTICULAR COMPANY. THEY GOT
CONTRACTS THEY WERE PUT. OUT OF
BUSINESS AND BROKEN. THERE IS
LITIGATION RIGHT NOW WITH WITH
THAT PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL
SHE'S OST HER HOME ENTER
BUSINESS. I JUST NEED TODAY. AN
URGENT EMAIL FROM THE FRESNO
RESCUE MISSION. SAYING JIM
PLEASE CAN THE LEGISLATURE CAN
YOU AND OTHERS INTERVENE FOR US.
THEY TOOK OUR PROPERTY THEY
PROMISED US THAT WE WOULD BE
PAID TO RE LOCATE AND TO
COMPLETE OUR CAMPUS THEY HAVE
RENEGED ON THAT PROMISE. HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS BEEN SO RECKLESS.
THAT AS EARLY AS TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. ON THE RECORD IN
DEPOSITIONS AND COURT IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WHERE FBI
AGENTS INTERVIEWED INDIVIDUALS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PART OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL. WE NOW HAVE A
VERY CONCERNED AND WORRIED
FEDERAL OVERSIGHT THAT IS
LOOKING AT HIGH SPEED RAIL
RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE BEEN. AND WE
HAVE BEEN RIPPED UP. AND SO I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT. A LONG OVERDUE
EFFORT BY THIS LEGISLATURE TO
SAY WHOA WHOA WAIT A MINUTE.
MAY BE THE ODD- OF THE CAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOUND SOME
THINGS THAT WERE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND SHE DID IT WAS
ADAPTING OUGHT. MEMBERS WE HAVE
TO BE MADE WHOLE. IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO HAVE A
RUMP RAILROAD. BETWEEN BAKER
SPEED AND MAYBE MADERA OR
MERCED. THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE HIGH SPEED TRAINS ON IT.
IT IS NOT WHAT WE WERE PROMISED.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR THE
RESOLUTION I THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITMENT HERE TO HOLD A HIGH
SPEED RAIL ACCOUNTABLE. AND
LET'S ALSO NOT ONLY HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY DO
BUT LET'S HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HOW THEY- DO IT. THEY ARE
NOT A ROGUE AGENCY ALTHOUGH
THEY LIKE TO ACT LIKE IT. THEY
HAVE MADE UP THIS PROJECT AS
THEY WENT ALONG. EVERY
ITERATION OF THEIR BUSINESS
PLAN HAS BEEN ESSENTIALLY A
BUNCH OF PROMISES AND THE NEXT
BUSINESS PLAN YOU SEE IS
ANOTHER TURN ANOTHER CURB
ANOTHER CHANGE ANOTHER. A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO IT. AND
SO THANK YOU FOR. THIS
BIPARTISAN AND I THINK VERY
STRONG MESSAGE TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL YOU DO US A FAVOR IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND MAYBE
YOU HELP. TO PUT IT BACK
TOGETHER AGAIN. AND TO GET
THOSE PAID PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
PROMISED PAYMENTS FOR THEIR
PROPERTY THEIR BUSINESSES. TO
BE PAID IT IS THE JUST AND
RIGHT THING TO DO AND I
APPRECIATE THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HERE FOR
THIS RESOLUTION I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE BUT IT
IS ALSO IMPORTANT FOR CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA HE TO BE HERE UP. WE
NEED TO BE- COOL AND THERE HAVE
SOMETHING OF VALUE HERE WHEN
ALL IS SAID AND DONE THANK YOU.
MR IMAGINARY CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MEDI SPEAKER I I'D THE CHORUS
IN SUPPORTING THIS HOUSE
RESOLUTION- AS A CO AUTHOR BUT
AS A VOICE AND THERE ARE
DIVERSE VOICES SPEAKING ABOUT
HIS REASON ONE IS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE CODE
BRAND EVER. AGING INSIDE
INVESTMENT AS MY COLLEAGUE MUST
MOST SIX OF THE QUIRKS PROJECT
IN CALIFORNIA. IT SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE LOCKED IN FOR
THREE YEARS IF WE DON'T MAKE
SURE WE DO IT RIGHT AND THAT
IMPACTS. KIND INVESTMENTS DOT
FOR TRANSPORTATION. YOU KNOW I
HAVE A VERY RARE THE UTILIZED A
RED BUTTON ON MY DESK. AND I
LOOKED NEXT YEAR TO STAYING NO
UNLOCKING A SET THIS PROJECT.
MANY REASONS WHY IT DOES IT
IT'S A LOT OF IT DOESN'T WORK
BASICALLY ACROSS ANSWER. YEAH
BUT THE NOW ONE IS ON OP CAUGHT
A REAL PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT
THAT MAKES SENSE HEREIN
SACRAMENTO IN MY DISTRICT
BETWEEN IN THE BAY AREA THE-
DESPITE THAT THAT'S THE FASTEST
HOUSE RAIL LINE IN THE COUNTRY
THROUGH AMTRAK. ARE YOU THREE
BILL MOVEMENTS WHICH WILL THE
CAPACITY DE THE OPERA TO LINK
THESE TWO ECONOMIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE PUT ALL OUR
MONEY INTO THIS BILL I THINK IN
IN IN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PLAN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES NOT TO MENTION.
THE METROLINK LINE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NOT TO MENTION
CALTRAIN BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THAT PENINSULA IN THE BAY
AREA SO THERE ARE MAJOR
SEQUENCES AND THIS IS THE
REASON WHY WE GET BEHIND
SUPPORT HR NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY
MISTER OBERNOLTE OUR
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF H. R. NINETY SEVEN
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS RESOLUTION I
THINK IT IS EXTREMELY PROPRIA
BUT THE LEGISLATURE STEP IN
HERE. TAKE OVER OUR HISTORIC
ROLE OF BEING A SEPARATE AND CO
EQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT. WE
HAVE WHAT THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
RUN THIS PROGRAM ESSENTIALLY
SINCE CAPTION. IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE TIME HAS COME FOR US TO
STEP UP. THE EXERCISE SOME
FISCAL OVERSIGHT OVER WHAT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS
DOING. IT'S VERY CLEAR TO ME.
THAT FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
BUSINESS AND OF OUR SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS PUT ON. IT WILL
NOT THE TERMS OF PROPOSITION
ONE A WHICH THE VOTERS APPROVED
TO START THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. SO I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE WE TAKE THIS PART.
IRAQ THE PARTY TO SEIZE ACT
MISSION OF. THAT THE- POSITION
OUR PROPERTY UNTIL WE HAVE HAD
A CHANCE TO EXAMINE THE UP PLAN
OF THE AUTHORITY. AND ON THE
LONG TERM PROSPECTS FOR THIS
PROP WITH FOR. NOW STILL A
POINT OUT AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WE HAVE. A
PROBLEM WITH GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDING RIGHT NOW ARE
CAP AND TRADE AUCTION REVENUE
HAS NOT BEEN AS EXPECTED
BECAUSE CORONAVIRUS PRICES. WE
HAVE A LOT OF VERY DESERVING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING TO GO
WITHOUT FUNDING THIS YEAR. AND
YET 25% OF THOSE G. R. F. ON.
OUR APPROPRIATED. WAS TO THE
HOSPITAL FORTY I THINK WE
SHOULD TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY
ARE MORE DESERVING PROGRAM THE
FUN. SO I WANT THANK YOU FOR
THE AUTHOR BRING RESOLUTION
FOR. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR THE. IS MIKE IS NOT ON.
THAT THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT
WOULD YOU MISSED IT WAS
PROFOUND TO YOU MISTER ALL I
ALSO RISE AND ASKED YOU VOTE
FOR HR NINETY SEVEN IN. THIS
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD CALIFORNIA DEPENDS ON
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION
MEANS SO MANY THINGS TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. SO WAY
THAT WE GET TO PLACES WE WANT
TO VISIT IT ALSO HAS A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
MOMENT. ON THE ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR ECONOMY AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
RATE THAT WE GET. SPEED RAIL
RIGHT. WE NEED TO EFFECTIVELY
SPENT MONEY ON PLACES THAT A
LARGE PORTION OF CALIFORNIANS
NEED TO GO. ON THEM. THERE
COULD. AND THAT BACK ON THE IN.
SYSTEM THAT DIRECTION JOE
TOWARDS A SO VALLEY IN A WAY
THAT BECOME SUS. WILL ALLOW FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WE KNOW THIS STATE NEEDS
THIS IS UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN IF
WE FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THE
CURRENT PLAN IT IS AN ADULT
BODY WHICH IS TAKEN LITTLE IN
FROM US. AGING AS TO DOLLAR
THAT WILL. TO DIE. FOR THE-
THIRTY YEARS THAT INCLUDES
DOLLARS FOR A MAINTENANCE
CONTRACT FOR A SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T EXIST AND THAT MAY
NEVER EXIST. THIS VOTE TODAY
ASKS THE HOT. ALREADY TO SLOW
DOWN AND CONSULT WITH THE WITH
US AND WITH THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK I
HAVE A FOR HR NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER FRAZIER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. PLEASE MADAM
SPEAKER. OUR COLLEAGUES- AS YOU
KNOW I WAS A CONTRACTOR FOR.
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE. I'VE THIS PROJECT
SEVERAL TIMES IN THE VALLEY I
WITH MY STAFF AND OTHER
COLLEAGUES TO HEAR THE
LEGISLATURE. WENT DOWN THERE I
SAW THINGS THAT LOOKED.
ABNORMAL I SAW THINGS IT LOOKS
THE SAME HAS WON THE LAST TIME
I WAS THERE. HOLD IT OF THIS
PROJECT. I AM NOT FOR SHUTTING
DOWN THIS PROJECT
YEARS NOW I'VE BEEN THE CHAIR
OF TRANSPORTATION OUR LAST. TO
BE AN EQUAL PARTNER WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL. FOR THE GOOD OR FOR
THE BACK THE WEEK A WORK
TOGETHER THROUGH SOLUTIONS. FOR
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. THAT BEING SAID I
HAD MY HAND TO MY CHEST THE
WHOLE TIME. NOT ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT I MIGHT BE ABLE TO BE
HELPFUL IN THIS ROLE IS THE
CHAIR. THERE POSSIBLY IS OTHER
SOLUTIONS NOW HAVE COME TO
LIGHT THAT MIGHT BE THE BETTORS
AND MONIES. THE PUT MORE RIDERS.
IN SEATS. BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION. WE HAVE TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THE
VOTERS WERE TOLD IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. CERTAIN THINGS.
AND THOSE THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE ACCOMPLISHED. THERE IS A
PRIVATE INVESTMENT VERY LITTLE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS IT NOW THAT
FUNDS FROM THE FED ARE NOW
BEING. POSSIBLY DUPLICATED.
WHAT I WILL TELL YOU IS THAT.
WE WANT TO HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHORITY
BEFORE THEY MAKE. DECISIONS
THAT PUT ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE HOOK FOR
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT. NOT WORK
OUT. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WOULD
YOU LIKE AUTHORS ON THE- YES
THE COURT THE ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO I. ROSE FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS
VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF A. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. YEAH. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT THERE
SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS ANY TURN
NINETY SEVEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. BACK TO THE FILE. WILL
PASS THIRTEEN AND FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE. WE WILL MOVE PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS. AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE WITH A MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
MISTER CARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU THIS IS SOLELY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDING THIS
MEASURE. THEY ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE ASKING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER PARTY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AYES HAVE IT. AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. WILL MOVE HAPPEN
FILE ITEM. TO FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
THE CLERK ILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS NOT RELATE TO A POINT
THE CLEAR TO SEE THEIR OF TOOK
EFFECT THE ONLY IF YOU ARE. THE
AB. FIFTY SO HAS OF THE- OF
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THEIR ONES WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN- CONSENSUS
REACHED I HAVE FULL CONSENSUS
REACHED FOR WRITERS. ARE I
ACTIONS A FULL CONSENSUS
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY THAT'S
GONNA OBJECT I ASSUME-
MULTIMEDIA PROFESSIONALS AND
VERY STAKEHOLDERS IN THE MUSIC
INDUSTRY- THIS THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS HAS AN URGENCY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO KEEP THIS
ONE GOING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN AS THERE'S
CONSENSUS IT AREAS PUT IT IN
THERE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
MEETING IT REALLY. THOSE ARE
DESIGNATED RESPECTFULLY ASK
FROM ABOUT. CHAMBER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THIS BILL EXEMPTS
CERTAIN PROFESSIONS AFTER
EIGHTY FIVE AND THEN ALSO
EXEMPTS THEM FROM THE MORE
MINOR IN PACKS OF A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SOMETHING COURT DINNER AYE
DYNAMICS INTERPRETED AN OBSCURE
ANTIQUATED PROVISION. IT'S
QUITE SIMPLY ARE I'VE HEARD
FROM A WATER WRITERS AND A LOT
OF MUSICIANS WHO SAY THAT THIS
RELIEF. WILL REALLY HELP THEM.
OUR SIDE THE BILL REINFORCES A
FRAMEWORK THAT IS TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CITIZENS AND GOVERNMENT. BEFORE
AB FIVE. YOU COULD WORK UNLESS
THE GOVERNMENT SAID NOW. NOW
YOU CAN'T WORK UNLESS THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS YES FREEDOM IS
GONE FROM THE NORMAL. TO THE
EXCEPTION. AND IN THINKING
ABOUT HOW THE WAY. THAT HARM I
FOUND IMPLEMENTED A STATEMENT A
COUPLE DAYS AGO FROM THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- AND I'D LIKE
PERMISSION TO READ A PORTION OF
THAT STATEMENT NOT. WITHOUT
THIS IS AND WE'RE NOT PRESIDENT
SHE'S THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CHAMBER OF CALL. BLACK LIVES
BLACK FAMILIES AND BLACK
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED
BY THE TRIPLE CATASTROPHES OF
AB FIVE COVERED NINETEEN AND
THE VIOLENT RACISM IT'S THE
VERY IN FUSION'S WE RELY ON. TO
PROTECT OUR FREEDOM. IT'S HE
CALLED EIGHT FIVE A MISS GOT
DID AND DISASTROUS LAW THAT IS
ROB THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
OF THEIR RIGHT TO EARN A LIVING
WITH DIGNITY RESPECT AND
INDEPENDENT. THE BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN WHO HAVE CHOSEN TO WORK
FOR THEMSELVES ARE NOT ASKING
FOR YOUR PROTECTION FROM SELF
EMPLOYMENT. WE ARE NOT ASK FOR
YOUR PERMISSION LIVING AS WE
CHOOSE BY END OF BUSINESS FOR
OURSELVES OR CONTROL OUR OWN
FUTURE AS IN THE- CONTRACTOR.
WE'RE TIGHT OF PATERNALISTIC
AND- IS THE PURPORT TO PROTECT
US WILL ENABLING DEFENDING AND
PROPAGATING THE SYSTEMIC RACISM
BUT IS CAUGHT SO MANY BLACK
CROSSED THOUSANDS OF BLACK
BUSINESSES AND WILL KEEP MORE
FROM OPERATING IN THE GIG
ECONOMY. NEAR THE MIDDLE
CALIFORNIANS LOSE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND INDEPENDENCE
THE FUTURE OF AB FIVE OR UP TO
YOU WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR YOUR
HELP. GUIDED PROTECT JUST FOR
AND- OUR- I HAVE A LEADERSHIP
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS ASSEMBLY
SPEAKING HIGH TONES ABOUT
ISSUES OF SOCIAL JUSTICE AND I
THINK IT'S JANUARY. BUT ALL IT
TAKES IS A PHONE CALL FROM A
BIG ENOUGH SPECIAL INTEREST AND
YOU'LL TURN YOUR BACK ON ANY
COMMUNITY WHICH IS WHY WHEN I
HEAR REPEATED CHEAP SHOTS AND
PERSONAL ATTACKS FROM THIS
AUTHOR OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE
CHAIR I DON'T ENGAGE WITH IT AT
ALL BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU IS.
PARTICULAR YEAH I JUST LATER.
ON THE MY LEFT. BUT WE ALL HAVE
CAPACITY TO CHANGE THAT WE ALL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO START
GOVERNING IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. ON THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW. WE COULD DECIDE
CONSCIOUSLY NOT JUST TO AWARD
FREEDOM IN SMALL DOSES BUT TO
START TREATING ALL CALIFORNIANS
OF THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT THEY
DESERVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER DOLLARS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AND I'VE A CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO THE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF A. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I
SEVENTY NEWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I'D SEVENTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE WILL
PASS THE ROUTINE AN FILE ITEMS
NINETY SIX THROUGH NINETY
EIGHT. WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEMS NINETY NINE AND ONE
HUNDRED IT'S- MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE OH ONE AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME OF BILL TWENTY SIX
SIXTY THREE BY MEMBERS ARE SEE
AN ACCOLADE MOTOR VEHICLE FUEL.
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE MAN SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. TWO SIX SIX THREE WILL
PROVIDE NECESSARY FACTORED
THREE. PROVISIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE. IN CALIFORNIA
REVENUE. AND TAXATION QUOTE TO
ENABLE THE COMMERCIALIZATION OF
DISPENSING THE AMY. WHEN
BLENDED WITH LIQUID PROPANE GAS
WHEN SOLD AND DISPENSE AT
RETAIL TO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC.
FOR USE OF MOTOR VEHICLE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA THINKING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. WHERE ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS
ARE THE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN CALAVERAS BY SIXTY NINE
IS YOUR THE MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT AND WANTED TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ THE MIDDLE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
ACTUALLY NO HEALTH CARE. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADISON CURRENT MEMBERS AB
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
ESTABLISHES REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE COMPLETION OF THE HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS BASED PROGRAM
HTTP PROGRAM WITHIN THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT HEALTHCARE
PRICES CONTINUE TO RISE AND
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY OUR
EFFORTS TO CONTAIN COSTS MUST
START IT. GRAHAM WILL BE THE
SINGLE MOST IN DATA. FOR CAL.
REST TO BE ABLE TO MEASURE
HEALTHCARE COSTS ANALYZE HEALTH
COST GROWTH RATES MOTOR
PERFORMANCE AND QUALITY
EVALUATE PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
TRACK CHRONIC DISEASES AND
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL HEALTH CARE
SAVINGS AND UNNECESSARY
SPENDING. AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY CREATE DOWN DATING FOR
ACHIEVING THE TRIPLE AIM OF
HEALTH CARE IMPROVING HEALTH
CARE REDUCE HEALTHCARE
DISPARITIES AND CONTROLLING
COSTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IBM. MR WED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE OPEN
THE- MEMBERS ARE THE- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A. QUIRK UP CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I
REFERRING AB EIGHT SIXTY BERMAN.
TO THE ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX BE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN TO
ADOPT AMENDMENTS TO ITEM ONE SB
THREE FIFTY HILL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MEMBERS THESE ARE
THE AMENDMENTS TO SB FIFTY. SB
THREE FIFTY CORRECTION.
COVERAGE SENATE BILL THREE
FIFTY WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN MR HOLDEN
ON THE MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS
CORRECT DRAFTING ERRORS TO MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE ACTIONS
OF THE UTILITY AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL EARLIER
THIS WEEK ASKED THAT THE
MINUTES BE ADOPTED IN THE BILL
GO OUT TO PRINT AND BACK. ON
FILE. THANK YOU MISTER ALL CASH
AND WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE MERITS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE
A- MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS
OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY. ANNOUNCEMENTS
THE DESK WILL BE HELD OPEN TO
PROCESS BUDGET RELATED
AMENDMENTS. SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY JUNE TWELFTH
OF FLOOR SESSION- CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY JUNE FIFTEENTH
FLOOR SESSION. IS AT ONE PM.
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
QUORUM CALLS IN PLACE MEMBERS
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALLS IN
PLACE PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
WE ARE THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
AGAIN MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE AYE RISE
PASSED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF SERGEANT DAMON CUTS
WERE. SEVEN LOSSES LIFE LAST
SATURDAY IN A TRAGIC SHOOTING
INCIDENT IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
AND HE WILL BE DEEPLY DEEPLY
MESS BY THAT SHERIFF'S OFFICE
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
GREAT SURE JIM HART. AND BY THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE HE WAS A
LOCAL BOY GREW UP. THE AREA AND
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC SERVICE A DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND PAY THAT APPRECIATION
FORWARD. STARTING CUTS WELLER'S
SURVIVED BY WIFE WHO'S OF JUST
A FEW WEEKS AWAY FROM
DELIVERING THEIR SECOND CHILD.
AND THE AND THE YOUNG SON. AND.
THIS IS A MEMBER OF A SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WHO EMBODIED COMMUNITY
POLICING WAS LOVE NOT ONLY BY
THE OFFICE BUT REALLY BY THE
COMMUNITY HE SERVES. BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTOOD THE COMMUNITY SO
WELL. AND THAT COMMUNITY
APPRECIATED WHAT HE BROUGHT.
THE TRAGIC INCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED LAST SATURDAY IS A
REMINDER OF HOW DANGEROUS THEIR
LIVES ARE. THIS WAS A SITUATION
THAT DID NOT NEED TO HAPPEN BUT
IT DID AND YET THE SERGEANTS
AND A DEPUTY WAS WITH HIM. WENT
INTO A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
AS THEY WOULD HAVE NORMALLY.
ENDED AND THAT ENDED UP WITH
THIS TRAGEDY THIS IS TRULY A
LOSS FOR ALL OF US IN SANTA
CRUZ AND REALLY TRULY A LOSS
FOR ALL OF US ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I ASK THAT
THIS BODY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF SERGEANT DAMON CUTS
WILL. THANK YOU MISTER STYLE.
MS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. I
MEMBERS I RISE SAYS THE
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL MEMORY OF
DAVID PATRICK UNDERWOOD WHO WAS
TRAGICALLY SHOT AND KILLED ON
THE EVENING OF MAY TWENTY NINTH
AT THE AGE OF FIFTY THREE.
WHILE WORKING AS A CONTRACT
SECURITY OFFER THE SECURITY
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. AND THE
RONALD TEMAS AT DOMES FEDERAL
BUILDING IN DOWNTOWN OAKLAND MR
UNDER WHAT A NATIVE OF PANEL
ATTENDED PINOLE VALLEY HIGH
SCHOOL AND THEN WENT ON TO BE A
STUDENT CONTRA COSTA. COLLEGE I
REMEMBER MR UNDER WHAT IS A
TALENTED ATHLETES HE GROUP HE
GREW UP PLAYING BASEBALL AND
PLAYED. WELL AND PLAY BASEBALL
FOR PERSONAL VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL
AND ALSO PLAYED BASKETBALL. AS
A PERSONAL SPARTAN. FRIENDS OF
MISTER UNDERWOOD DESCRIBED HIM
AS BEING A GOOD MAN. THAT
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY
LOVES. SOMEONE WHO IS
CHARISMATIC. WHO SPIRITS LIFTED
THE ROOM WHEN HE WALKED IN.
FROM OF SPORT AND COMMUNITY
MISSED UNDER WAS ACTIVE. IN HIS
WORK TO HELP OTHERS AS A
REGULAR SUPPORTER OF THE KEY IF
COMMUNITY GROUP SOULFUL
SOFTBALL SUNDAYS. AND
ORGANIZATION THAT ANNUALLY
GATHERS COMMUNITY MEMBERS FOR
SOFTBALL UNITY. AND RESOURCES.
AND OTHERS A IN ADDITION TO
OTHER ACTS OF CHARITY
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. THROUGHOUT
HIS WORK AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT
MISTER UNDERWOOD CONVEYED.
POSITIVITY COMPASSION AND
EMPATHY. HOW MANY IN THE
COMMUNITY. INCLUDING HIS FRIEND
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WILL MISS.
DAVID PATRICK UNDERWOOD LEAVES
BEHIND A FIANCE. LOVING FOR
MEMBERS FRIENDS AND A
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY THAT IT
CURRENTLY PLANNING. A SOFTBALL
GAME IN HONOR. I ASK THIS HOUSE.
THANK YOU MISS WICKS. MR RAHMAN
SHARE A CASHIER GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RISE REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF DENNIS HAS BURGER
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MAY SIX AT
THE AGE OF SEVENTY EIGHT.
GERMAN HANDS BURGER SERVED ON
THE SALMON YOU KNOW COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REPRESENTING THE THIRD DISTRICT
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO UNTIL
NINETEEN EIGHTY. AND THEN AGAIN
FROM NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. HE WAS
SELECTED TO BE THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND
AGAIN FROM TWO THOUSAND TWO AND
TO SELL INTO UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR. CHAIRMAN HANS BERGER
WAS BORN OCTOBER FIRST NINETEEN
FORTY ONE. IN REDLANDS TO LEROY
AND HELEN HANDS BURGER. A
GRADUATE OF REDLANDS HIGH
SCHOOL HE ATTENDED SAN MARINO
VALLEY COLLEGE AND UC
RIVERSIDE. GERMAN HANS BERGER
BEGAN HIS PUBLIC LIFE IN
SERVICE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
BETWEEN AS SERVICE IN YEARS IN
OFFICE CHAIRMAN HAS BURGER
REMAINED A DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT SERVING THREE YEARS AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE REDLANDS
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. HE ALSO SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF MULTIPLE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND AGENCIES
INCLUDING CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SAMBAR DINO. DECEMBER DINO
COUNTY MUSEUM THE INLAND EMPIRE
COUNCIL OF THE BOY SCOUTS OF
AMERICA AND THE CAPITAL
PROJECTS COMMITTEE OF THE GIRL
SCOUTS OF AMERICA. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX CHAIRMAN HAS BURGER
REENTERED GOVERNMENT AND WAS
AGAIN ELECTED TO SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. HE SERVED IN
THIS POSITION FOR TWELVE YEARS.
FOCUSING ON COMMUNITY
IMPROVEMENTS AND EFFORTS IN THE
REDLANDS AREA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTY. CHAIRMAN HANDS BURGER
WAS A PILLAR OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE COMMUNITY FOR HIS ENTIRE
LIFE. HIS WIFE KAREN WE SEND
OUR PRAYERS AND THOUGHTS TO HER.
WE THANK HIM FOR ALL THAT HE'S
DONE TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR THE RESIDENTS IN SAN
MARINO COUNTY AND I ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS ROSS MR MAYES YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET
GERMAN A MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANTED TO
RISE- A TO ALSO PROVIDE VOICE-
TWO OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM A SEMI
WILL RESERVATION IN REGARDS TO.
A SUPERVISOR DENNIS HANS BERGER
I DENNIS- WAS A MENTOR TO ME I
HAD THE HONOR OF BEING ABLE TO
WORK FOR SUPERVISOR HANS
BERGER. I HE WAS A GIANT- OF A
FIGURE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
SERVING FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND EVERYBODY WHO'S
IN THIS ROOM TODAY. A FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE KNOWS WHO- DENNIS
IS AND WILL SPEAK INCREDIBLY A
HIGHLY OF HIM HE WAS SOMEBODY
THAT BELIEVE THAT OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS BUT WE A NO. PERFECT
BELIEVE. AT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
IN PUBLIC THERE WAS ALL ABOUT.
AND SOME OF THE LESSONS THAT
I'VE LEARNED FROM HIM- I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO EXECUTE THOSE IN
THIS VERY ROOM. I WHAT I HEARD
OF HIS PASSING I'LL TELL YA- I
CRIED- BUT BECAUSE HE WAS
SOMEBODY. THAT I WILL- I WILL
MISS A BUDDY SOMEBODY THAT I
WILL THINK OF ALL. OF FOREVER
AND SO ALSO WHEN IT AT JUST ADD
MY THOUGHTS AND INJURING HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
MESS. YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF THE DESERT PRINT
IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED
YOUR MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS. I
AM READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MR TING MOVES
MISTER FLORES SECONDS. AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED. UNTIL
MONDAY. JUNE FIFTEENTH AT ONE
PM A QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO AB THREE
TWO SIX TWO FROM NO TO NOT
VOTING. BURKE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO NO
TO NOT VOTING.